Good evening. In compliance with chapter
551 open meetings of the Texas
Government Code, I call to order a
public hearing meeting of the board of
trustees of the Austin Independent
School District for Thursday, November
20th, 2025 at 5:01 p.m. A quorum of the
board is physically present at the
Austin ISD central office to conduct
this meeting. This meeting is being
broadcast on cable channel 22 through
Spectrum Aound Broadband and on channel
99 through AT&T Universe. Closed
captioning in English is available on
these platforms for individuals who are
deaf or heart of hearing. Welcome and
thank you for joining us and Trusty
Gonzalez is joining us by Zoom tonight.
Um, next is an opportunity for the
public to share comments with the board.
This time around allows speakers to
comment publicly pertaining to the
turnaround plans. There will be an
opportunity to comment about other items
after the hearing. members of the public
wishing to participate in the public
hearing portion of our meeting called a
dedicated Austin ISD phone line in
advance of the meeting to sign up to
speak in person or to audio record their
remarks. Tonight we have four people who
signed up to speak in person and we have
six people who left a recorded message
for the hearing and we will now move to
in-person testimony. In order to provide
as many opportunities for input as
possible within a limited time period at
this meeting, each speaker is allotted
one minute. No substitutions or yielding
of time to others is permitted. Callers
who signed up to speak in person, uh,
please come to the microphone when your
name is called. As you come to the
microphone, please press the button to
turn the microphone on. There will be a
device that will light up as you move
through your one minute of allotted
time. And when the buzzer sounds, we ask
that you please make a final thought in
one sentence. Uh, and we ask that
whether you come to give a complaint or
praise, that you reference any staff
member by position or abbreviated last
name. And we ask that all audience
members, whether speaking or not, please
show respect for others at all times. Uh
we have four in-person speakers tonight.
Amber Welsh, Relle Olivar, Olivas or
Olivaris, uh Jason Rodriguez, and
Senovio Santander.
Okay, two things. Um, first I want to
let y'all know, uh, it's been a real
challenge to participate in the TAP
development process as a parent at a TAP
campus. Um, a group from the district
visited our campus, presented three
options, but we only received more
information from the district after they
had decided that closed reassign was
best for our students. And we still
haven't been able to figure out or find
out more about which options were
considered or why close reassign was
determined to meet our students needs.
And I would just ask for greater
transparency throughout the process,
including when decisions will be made,
how they'll be made moving forward
related to transitions. Um,
additionally, my second thing is, as
y'all know, community is a real asset as
a part of student learning. Um, and we
really want to be involved in
discussions about planning and
implementation,
but communicating with district staff
related to TAPS has been nearly
impossible. Um,
oh my gosh, this yellow light is
stressing me out. Anyway, please
communicate with us better. We want to
work with you. We're all rooting for
this to work because our kids want to
learn. And so, reach out if you have
more questions.
[applause]
>> Hello. Good evening. I am a parent of a
third grader at Weed Dayne Elementary.
The vote that you are making tonight
will change the landscape for 50 years.
Each of the taps that you have closure
reassigned deserve an individual vote so
that we can go back in history to this
moment and understand if there could
have been a different outcome.
Each of the taps have been district-led,
have been district written. We have been
allow we the community have been allowed
to comment but not vote. We have been
allowed to review but not edit. Tonight,
you will be presented with a
community-led plan that calls for a
restart of Weedane Elementary.
I urge you to trust the community and be
brave and vote for this restart of
Weedane Elementary. Closure to Wedane
would desecrate the decadesl long
partnership that has been built to make
a community school a nationally
recognized model in southeast Austin.
[applause]
Hello, I'm Jason Rodriguez. with Widane
Elementary and in front of you y'all
have an amendment for a restart and not
a closure. It's almost physically
impossible to close our school and put
us with another one. It y'all just need
to take a a close look at that. Y'all
are not only closing the school, y'all
are ripping our hearts out. Y'all are
taking us out of the community. Our
community is fed with several resources
around the city and the neighborhood.
And it would be vital just to keep it
open. Even if it's not under Widane, uh,
put it under another name. Whatever
y'all got to do to keep going to make
this work. Another question I have is
what's with the 50-year plan? What about
now? We got to worry about what's
happening these next three years. And
why aren't y'all taking advantage of
y'all vital assets? And that's us
parents. I've seen them do amazing
things. They've worked with other
people. And I've seen our faculty do
even more things. So, y'all need to take
more consideration in what's around
y'all in communities and not just be
absolute with things.
Thank you.
[applause]
>> Good afternoon. My name is Senovio
Center. I just ask y'all this afternoon
to uh I have two kids. I have a second
grader and I have a fifth grader at
Widane. Uh we ask y'all to to stop,
look, and listen. Uh plan A should
always be as we talk. That should be the
community plan. Uh and listen to the
community, what we have out there, what
options we have. Uh we have very strong
teachers uh passionate teachers at
Widane. Uh we ask y'all for a restart
for my name. Uh y'all have left the
Latino community out for a long period
of time. We have left behind and this is
uh why it's just the center of the
community that still holds and uh just
amazing uh people around it. the school,
uh the teachers, I mean the staff there
and all the parents also that just come
together on a daily basis to make this
uh to make the kids just a great day
each and every day. So, thank you'all.
[applause]
Thank you. We will now play the recorded
message for public uh public testimony.
So, please listen carefully.
My name is Nikki. I'm a AIS parent. In
the season of thanks, I want to say
thank you to the principles at our tax
school. The Calgary finally came to
serve your schools and is trampling
right over you. AIS showed up too late
and is taking your job and your students
away and I'm so sorry. You aren't the
cause of your school's closing. Thank
you for the many more months that you
will work this year to grow your
schools. And thank you for the years you
invested in them back when it was just
you and your school community and the
area nonprofit supporting the work. Your
commitment is obvious and our thanks
should be coming from every corner of
Austin ISD.
Thank you to ISD staff and trustees for
the monumental work that you've been
doing involved in rightsiding our
community and our schools and our
district. Thank you for families at
Sunset Valley, Rididgetop, and Riley for
your readiness to build community and
continue in bilingual education. The
teachers and leaders will make all the
difference in the years at ahead at your
new schools. Thank you to the teachers
at TAP campuses. The work you do doesn't
always receive the respect and pay it
deserves despite
Delay the vote on closures,
consolidations, and program changes.
approved taps with research. This
district tore apart Doby Bernett and web
that harm still echoes. Please don't
repeat it. We keep hearing we have to do
hard things, but hard things are
investing in our school communities.
Hard things are trimming administrative
excess so we can pay teachers and fund
campuses. Hard things would have been
implementing tax two and a half years
ago. So we weren't one step from TDA
takeover. That failure was not on the
community. It was on leadership.
Leadership was warned and they said we
have systems. We won't be here. But if
they have systems, they don't work. We
were promised cuts away from campuses
first. We got performative cuts,
increased spending, fasttrack school
closures built largely by two people now
in leave for lack of integrity of the
process. As the district said that issue
has
>> Good evening trustees, superintendent
and staff. This is Ann Ty, former AIC
trustee 2012 2020 and retired AIST
educator of 34 years. Speaking to agenda
item 3.1, I urge the trustees to approve
the plans outlined in 3.1. It's the
right thing to do. Ensure the to ensure
the success of AISD students now and in
the future. AISD's core mission is to
educate students. Identifying the
resources needed to accomplish that
mission take precedence over the agendas
of some adults. Trustees, it is not the
right thing to do the bidding of a small
group of local constituents who either
do not understand or respect the overall
burden faced by the district because of
state action or inaction or who do not
understand or respect the needs of all
AIST students, especially the most
vulnerable ones. I congratulate the
superintendent and the trustees for
taking this bold step. It will go a long
way to providing equity in the
distribution of resources needed to
educate our students so they become
principled critical creative thinkers
who can pursue life, liberty, and
happiness in the 21st century and
beyond. Change is hard and uncertainty
is hard. But we live in a world of
constant change and uncertainty. We need
to learn to react to change and
uncertainty by being proactive and with
mindfulness, not with anger. Peace out.
>> My name is Patrick Bettis. I'm a parent
of a child at Wedane Elementary and
calling to just say let's let's do a
restart. Let's not close the campus.
There's already a lot of damage that's
being done. Let's mitigate that. Let's
do something different. Let's pull
together for our kids. Make the
investments into these schools that
they've needed for a while. And don't
close these schools because you're going
to be destroying the community.
>> Good evening. This is Rachel Bettz. I am
a parent of a child that's in the
special education program at Weddane
Elementary. I just wanted to add my
thoughts and ask trustees to please vote
yes on restarting Weddane if um that is
our option that's left. We have found
such a surprising blessing there. All of
the staff um the principal he's out with
the kids. He knows our son by name. He
is so friendly and so professional. Um
truly cares about the students. And then
um the teacher name um has been such a
blessing for our son. But um considering
the neurode divergence there, we are
hoping for as little amount of change as
possible. We are fortunate enough to be
able to walk to school, which is also a
blessing. And we would just would love
to see the location continue at minimum.
Thank you for your consideration. And I
know these decisions are tough, but
yeah, we would love to see Wedane remain
open and that building remain open. um
for a restart. Thank you so much. God
bless. Bye-bye.
>> My name is Carol Regley. I have my
doctorate in occupational therapy and am
an adjunct faculty at ACC East View. I
urge you to keep the historic school Oak
Springs Elementary open because closing
it would undermine the very equity goals
we all share. This campus is more than a
building. It is an anchor in an
education hub that includes ACC and the
early college high school. The students,
many from historically marginalized
communities, walk to the school. They do
not have transportation to another
campus. Relocating would immediately
create barriers to attendance, safety,
and academic stability. The district has
already invested millions in
redeveloping this campus. The school is
fully staffed this year, including
interventionists who were previously
missing. Even under past staffing
shortages, this campus nearly met the
standard this year. With the right
support, it is poised to exceed it. We
cannot achieve educational equity by
disrupting communities or by placing the
burden on our youngest learners. Closing
the school would not solve a problem. It
would create deeper ones. Let's honor
our investment, our students, and our
commitment to equity by preserving this
campus and giving it the stability it
needs to thrive. Thank you.
>> Thank you to all of our callers and our
speakers. This concludes our public
testimony. Uh trustees, are there any
questions seeking clarification?
All right. Thank you. Uh we'll have more
public Oh, yes. Sorry. Yes.
>> No, I I have a question for uh the
superintendent. Um as we are preparing
for taps, I I really am
wondering I know that you've mentioned
that you really want to take things to
tea that we know will be approved so
that we can begin the work uh and
continue the work that people are
already doing.
Would it be possible to take a school
that has shown progress and ask for
additional time?
>> I do not believe that would be possible
for us to do.
>> You don't believe it would be possible
for us to do or you don't believe that
TEA would accept it?
>> I don't I do not believe TEA would
accept it.
>> Okay.
I'm
saddened because some schools have been
struggling. They've been struggling all
along, but we also have schools that are
making that incremental progress and why
our state would then say, "No, we don't
want to give you more additional help. I
think Trusty Wichu has has um beaten
this horse and I agree. It is punishment
to not reward people when they are
making those gains." And um I
specifically speaking uh about when and
because it is a Monasuri school and um
we have to have a place for that. Our
community wants that and um I I can tell
you that the new plan that has come out
it it is doable but um
there has to be a lot of work done to
transition this community into its new
community. Um, and there has to be a
commitment to this work to to do what we
said we were going to do. Thank you.
Anyone else with comments about our
testimony clarification?
>> All right. Thank you. Uh, as a reminder
to our community, please feel free to
share uh comments or questions on items
with the board by email at
trusteesaustinisd.org.
and we will have more public comment and
public testimony uh when we get to our
voting meeting after the hearing is
over. Thank you. So, next up is our
presentation on the turnaround plans
that the administration has created and
um is recommending that we send to the
Texas Education Agency. Uh Mr. Sigur,
would you please introduce this item?
>> Yes. Thank you, uh President Boswell.
I'd like to invite up um Dr. Latana
Anders Anderson, assistant
superintendent of school improvement.
Jennifer Pace, assistant superintendent
of elementary school leadership, Dr.
Angel Wilson, assistant superintendent
of secondary school leadership, Dr.
Maryanne Maxwell, assistant
superintendent of academics, and Brandy
Hosek, uh, talent and strategy officer.
Um, and so before we get going and
before I hand it over to the team, I I
want to just um kind of acknowledge the
variety of things that we are working
through concurrently. Um certainly the
turnaround plans and the work that we've
done uh has has been intentional. It is
important that we recognize that it has
to be in compliance with Texas Education
Agency uh requirements. But it's also
occurring at a time when AISD is working
through many other things including
budget deficits, program realignments,
the ever shifting accountability system
which I think Trusty Hunter just maybe
was referencing. uh and all an effort
for us as a school district to stabilize
and move to a a period of time when we
have strong neighborhood schools that
every student can access uh in Austin.
And so as we transition to the next
slide, I want to be really clear that
turnaround plans are required uh once a
school um receives two unacceptable
counts. And I'll be really clear, an
acceptable count uh can be um gained in
a variety of ways. One way is to have
three consecutive D's. Another way that
will give you one and or another way
would be just to have one F or two Fs.
Um so when we think about uh the
accumulation of the ratings, sometimes
they go back to 2018, 2019. Um and uh we
include the history uh in our turnaround
plans, but uh just to be crystal clear,
um different combinations of
unacceptable ratings can contribute to
the count. Uh but once you receive your
second unacceptable account, you then
are required by order of the
commissioner to develop a turnaround
plan. In most cases, the turnaround
plans are developed in year two and then
you implement in year three and then you
have two years to kind of ensure that
the plan works and ultimately break the
accountability chain before the fifth
year. Uh the there are different types
of uh success criteria that the uh
agency offers uh to be explored. It's
also important to note that whenever you
have comprehensive changes as we do, uh
there are often um kind of things that
you have to consider and that's where
conversations with the agency become
become very critical. Uh we do not have
the ability to um submit um plans that
will be unsuccessful or not accepted. Um
there is a period where they'll re
review and provide feedback and
responses but ultimately before uh we
have um a plan uh implemented it must be
accepted or we risk further escalation
via state intervention up to
installation of a board of managers
which we'll talk about more in a moment.
As we go to the next slide I want to um
call out the six different strategies
that are available to all school
districts across the state of Texas um
whenever you build a turnaround plan. Um
just being really precise, we have six
which include the intensive curriculum
and instruction improvement uh often
called school improvement. Uh restart
district managed. This is what uh we
have done at Bernett Web and Doby. We
have a restart partner managed uh which
is um what you know our our community
might um kind of as a reference point
look to Mendes and our partner that's
operating Mendes. Currently, we have a
closure and reassign uh where the
students are reassigned to a a school
that um has a C or better rating. Uh and
in that instance, the TAP is assigned to
that school. We have a new school
district managed. I want to be really
really clear. A new school has to be
new. It has to be a new scope, meaning
new programming or serve a different
student population. And so you can do
that uh as a district um uh run school
or you can have a partner do it. So
those are your six options. I also want
to be really clear that the system is
designed to give school districts fewer
and fewer options as they progress along
the unacceptable accountability
um kind of chain. Uh meaning that if you
have two UAS uh all six are available to
you. If you have three, it is unlikely
that school improvement will be made
available to you because the idea from
the agency's perspective is that the
intervention should meet the urgency
around um the the kind of unacceptable
accountability chain that's been created
for that campus. Um, the other thing I
want to call out, go back if you don't
mind, um, that if a school receives it
receives its fifth unacceptable
accountability rating, the commissioner
shall, um, and shall is an important
word because he's required to do this,
order the closure of the school or
install a board of managers. Um, and uh,
this is something uh that is often
referred referred to as a dis a state
takeover. This is what we're talking
about. Um, and uh, as we talk about in
the next couple slides, the work that
we're doing at Bernardet Webb and Doby,
those three schools are currently in
their fifth year. Um, so a lot of focus,
a lot of intentionality. Um, and we've
talked about that in the past, but I
want to be sure we all understand that
that is currently the case as we speak.
Um, as we transition to the next slide,
uh, I want to also communicate to our
trustees and community that, uh, the
1882 contingency and what this means is
that a partner that has demonstrated the
ability to, uh, restart or turn around a
campus going from a an F to a C or
better, um, if it's completed by a
partner and they've demonstrated that
success in the past, an organization
like a school district or school
district can enter into an agreement and
have them run the school. And when that
occurs, the state offers a pause, a
two-year pause period. Um, whenever a
school is in its fifth year, you can
actually um have the turnaround plan
approved or amended by the agency and
they can allow you to pursue the 1882
contingency plan and then that fifth
year ends up becoming your first of the
two-year pause. And so, uh, as we did
with Bernet, Web and Doby back on June
26 of this last of this year, we, um,
stated that, uh, we have that ability in
all of our, um, turnaround plans, uh, to
the district. I also want to be really
clear that we note this in many of the
turnaround plans, but not all. And the
reason for that is if you um state that
the 1882 contingency is available at all
the turnaround plans, it could um create
uh con a challenge for the district to
staff that school if it's a school that
is receiving a turnaround plan from
another school. An example of this would
be Betachch. So Betachch's turnaround
plan is being assigned to Covington. And
so we want to be really clear that in
that instance because Cington um
currently does not have any UAS but is
receiving the turnaround plan from
Betachch um we do not want um the staff
or the community to feel as though the
AT2 contingency is part of that work
because it's it's different and and we
just wanted to be really kind of clear
around when we're using it in the
language and when we're not. Um but
again we have that ability regardless if
it's in the plan um or not.
As we go to the next slide, uh just a
little bit of about the history of
Austin ISD. Um as I said, uh these um
unaccessible accountability chains go
back to the 1819 school year. Uh most
notably the c the schools that have four
UAS um in this case being Bernardet, Web
and Doby. Um I gave a presentation and I
shared with the community I think last
Friday where I went through every school
and one of the things that was
reinforced in that presentation was just
the number of schools that shifted in
accountability between the 22 and 23
school year which is when the um summit
of assessment or star changed. Uh we had
many many schools uh near a dozen um
that went from a B to an F. And uh
unfortunately some of those schools are
part of the turnaround plans that we
have here. Uh so when you think about it
kind of the assessment changed
summitative assessment changed these
schools dropped down and they've been
building back up but they still have not
been able to break the accountability
chain. Uh as you can see here the system
is we've been working very hard. Um just
two data points I think worth calling
out is you know from last year to this
year in 2425 we've had an increase in
schools that were rated A and a decrease
um in schools that were um rated an F
and I do expect that to go down
significantly uh this year as well.
Next slide please. I'm gonna now hand it
over um to uh Dr. Ammerson to take us
through the next set of slides.
>> Thank you. Uh good evening board of
trustees, secret superintendent Sagura.
Um as we reflect on this school
improvement work that um we are
currently um existing in with Dolby Webb
and Bernardet, we want to share some
lessons that we've learned and how we're
going to turn those lessons into
opportunities. Um lessons learned from
our research efforts reinforce that
strong systems, datadriven decision
making and collaboration are essential
for student growth. The effective use of
high-quality instructional materials
combined with leadership coaching and
targeted professional development helps
build and sustain teacher effectiveness.
Strategic staffing practices, targeted
and early recruitment, proactive vacancy
management along with operational
planning such as student data trackers
and targeted interventions are critical
to ensuring coordinated and successful
campus improvement.
to take what we've learned and transform
them into opportunities. I first want to
say that the school improvement work is
already underway. We have already
started those efforts, but we will
transform our learn lessons into
opportunities. We will strengthen
planning, staffing efforts, and student
supports. Data-driven decisions will
guide instruction and recruitment and
retention will be enhanced through more
strategic staffing. Collaborative
planning will align general and special
education instruction while family
engagement will expand through clear tap
communication, athome partner support,
adult ESL programs, and enrollment
assistance complemented by expanded
wraparound services. Instructional
improvements will include a revised
master schedule, expanded electives and
interventions, and continuations of the
lighthouse program and professional uh
development will be targeted.
Some examples that will show how what we
have experienced previously prior to the
TAP implementation as to what they will
expect going forward um are next on my
list of things to share with you. The
first example would be for the middle
school restart. To maximize teaching and
learning opportunities, campuses will
have increased learning time. The
recommended schedule would shift from a
four period day to a five period day,
reducing individual class periods for
approximately 90 minutes to 70 while
increasing the overall weekly
instructional minutes. The revised
schedule provides 450 minutes per week
for ELA, which is reading and writing
and math and 270 minutes per week for
science and social studies. The model
will also introduces one extended day
session per week and expands access to
summer school opportunities to support
additional learning time for students
who need it.
Family engagement
is that the next slide, please. Family
engagement is also an area that we're
going to deepen supports for our
campuses. We're going to be utilizing
the dual capacity building framework is
developed by Dr. Karen Mount from
Harvard University. It is a
researchbased model for family school
partnerships. The model calls for
engagement practices that are learning
focused, relational, collaborative,
developmental, and culturally
responsive. It shifts the family
engagement from isolated events to
sustained partnerships that support
school improvement.
And for the next slide, I will turn it
over to Dr. Maxwell.
Good evening. Um, so an important piece
of this work is how we are evaluating
what's happening, how we're evaluating
the progress of our students and and our
campuses while all of this is being
implemented. And so uh the table in
front of you is an example really of all
the things that we collect throughout
the year. Some of them are key
benchmarks and some of them are just
ongoing uh pieces of information that we
collect. On the left hand side of the
table, it's more quantitative in nature.
And then moving towards the right hand
side of the table, qualitative in
nature, which is really important
because we don't want to just depend on
uh strict scoring of assessments that we
see, but we also want to make sure that
what we're seeing in student work, what
we're seeing in practices on the
campuses, in PLC's, what we're seeing in
in classroom um practices and student
behaviors in classrooms are really
matching everything that we're also
seeing in uh student outcomes in their
assessments. And so all of these are
things that we we gather throughout the
year. Um what we and and many of these
assessments of course we've talked about
are our map growth which we collect
several times a year. In this instance
really beginning of year and middle of
year are are very key to see where we
are at by the middle of year to know to
make solid projections for where we'll
be at the end of year. Um star interim
which is an very early spring is also
another good indicator of that.
Curriculum based assessments are things
that we collect along the way and we can
look at overall percent scores for
those. Also an important piece of that
is student writing. We collect extended
constructed responses and short
construct constructed responses in those
assessments and use common rubrics to
evaluate student writing. And so that's
a way that we really look at student
work and analyze their writing. Of
course we have campus level assessments
um and data trackers that and that
campuses put into those data trackers.
Those are teacher created assessments.
They can be formal in nature, they can
be very informal in nature, but it's
collected at the campus level um and
shared with us. And of course, we have
campus observations. We're out on uh
campuses at district level walkthroughs.
And then we have uh technical partners
that also join us on those walkthroughs.
So we have two sets of observational
data that we can calibrate on um in the
classrooms and then also in PLC's. It's
a big part of what we see in practices
at campuses. The timeline for this of
course starts with beginning of year map
uh our map growth assessments and then
what we can do with that at beginning of
year is really look at just historically
where we've been at beginning of year uh
with the campuses to kind of uh check uh
at the beginning where we are. There's
ongo data ongoing data collection with
our curriculum based assessments and
with observations and teacher
assessments and the student work that
we're seeing happen. And then by middle
of year map and then the early spring
STAR interim particularly by middle
ofear map we have uh strong predictions.
We can make strong projections for where
students will perform on the star test
at the end of the year. Those
middle-of-ear map projections uh map
star projected proficiency scores are
anywhere between uh lower 80s to upper
80s as far as their accuracy for
predicting where we'll be in STAR. So
depending on the content area 84 to 85%
up to 88% they're even just a little bit
in in our district we found our our our
CDA department has found they're just a
little bit more reliable even than the
star interim uh projections. And so on
the next slide too, what what we wanted
to make sure uh we called out here is
all of those systems um are really
centered around what we've developed for
stronger robust systems for student
centered planning. Our MTSS system is
really at the at the heart of this
really knowing where each student is and
um identifying what they need and having
a response plan. So, we start with that
data collection, NPLC's or CSTs, which
are our um uh campus study teams, our
campus study teams,
uh lots of acronyms, um that are that
are part of our MTSS process. Uh they
collect especially for students that
we're worried about receiving that might
need interventions. They collect
additional data um progress monitor for
our students and we have action plans
for each student. So at and part of what
we provide at the district level, our
CDA department provides early how kids
have performed historically, where they
are at even coming into the year and
then additionally how they're doing
right now. And so those are
individualized per students so that we
know where every student is and that's
part of the information. It really
centers around all of that information
that's ongoing. So it's not just us
looking at this from outside, but it's
really dependent on the information
[clears throat] that we're receiving and
and that campuses are gathering about
students as well. So from the student
experience, they'll start with that
beginning of year MAP. They'll move on
to ongoing assessments like teacher
created curriculum based assessments and
things happening in the classroom. And
then again by middle of year u they'll
take MAP again and start interim and
we'll have a pretty good projection to
uh either finish the year with
intensified interventions or do exactly
what that student needs. We get good
information from all of those
assessments to make sure that we're
making good student centered plans.
Okay. Good evening, trustees. President
Boswell, Superintendent Sigora. Um, our
turnaround approach is intentional. Each
campus has been matched with the
strategy that best aligns to its needs,
capacity, and long-term sustainability.
Seven campuses are designated for
closure, reassignment, moving students
to campuses with stronger systems and
capacity. That's Bington, Betachch,
Dawson, Oak Springs, Martin,
Win, Montasauri, and Wedane. Five
campuses are moving into a restart model
using the ACE framework to dramatically
strengthen instructional systems. That's
Linder, Sanchez, Pedis, Pan Springs, and
Wooldridge. And then 12 campuses will
implement a school improvement strategy
focused on intensive curriculum and
instructional coherence for
acceleration. That's TA Brown, Go
Valley, Hart, Houston, Jordan, Norman,
Sims, Overton, Padron, Pickle, Saddler,
Means, Wooten, and East Side. Um, Early
College High School included for its
federal label. And I want to emphasize
that the strategy assigned to each
campus was not chosen lightly. These
decisions were part of a broader effort
to build stronger, more sustainable
neighborhood schools across Austin ISD.
In determining the most appropriate
strategy for each campus, we considered
community input, whether the plan would
be accepted by TEA under state law,
current and projected student
enrollment, the condition of facilities
and modernization projects, the
proximity and performance of nearby
schools, and multi-year achievement
trends. to select the strategy that
gives each campus the greatest
likelihood of success and that best
positions our district to improve
outcomes for students long term.
Next slide, please.
Most elementary students are being
reassigned to or most students period
are being assigned to um nearby AB or C
schools. Dawson to Galindo, Oak Springs
to Blackshere. The majority of Bington
to Guerrero Thompson, the majority of
Betich to Covington, and the majority of
Martin to Keeling.
Do have Dane assigned to Rodriguez,
which is currently derated but was
berated the previous year, and the
majority of Wyn assigned to Andrews,
which is a D-rated campus, and a smaller
percentage to Pan Springs, currently a
3UA restart campus. A smaller percentage
of Betachch is assigned to Pareetis,
currently a 3UA campus, and a smaller
percentage of Martin assigned to
Marshall, a D-rated campus.
We approached all student assignment
decisions thoughtfully and iteratively
with a focus on aligning moves to
accountability requirements while
keeping students connected to their
communities.
Receiving campuses were selected based
on proximity and available capacity and
we carefully considered accountability
ratings and performance trends
throughout the process. We made multiple
revisions in direct response to
community feedback to ensure that the
final assignments were both thoughtful
and feasible. In cases where students
are moving to a restart campus or a
D-rated campus, we were intentional um
about keeping the number of reassigned
students manageable and aligned to the
level of resources and support the
district can provide.
Our goal has been and continues to be to
create a transition plan that is
community responsive, instructionally
sound, and positioned to deliver
stronger outcomes for students. To
support this, all restart and d-rated
receiving campuses will receive
substantial additional resources,
including enhanced leadership, coaching,
increased staffing, and targeted
academic interventions.
>> Good evening, trustees and
superintendent Sigura. Um would like to
talk to you a little bit about those
investments uh and resources. So, uh,
starting all the way to the right on our
school improvement, which would be with
our two UAS, uh, would, um, an
additional a lotment for staffing. It's
really important that, um, we provide
guidance on that, but also allow our
principal of that school to say these
are the these are the positions that are
most beneficial to this campus. Every
campus is nuanced and every situation is
different. And so being able to provide
um uh you know general aotment of
dollars for staffing and and have their
input is incredibly important. Same goes
for our restarts and and reassignments
in in the restart and reassignment
column as you see there. Um again having
incredible uh principal discretion along
with their executive directors about
what are the what are some high leverage
positions you can bring on. Um, on some
campuses it may be that a graduation
coach is the is the highest leverage
piece that that they might need to to
get through the barrier. On others it
may be that more content
interventionists uh might be what they
would choose to bring on. Um, so again
principal autonomy with that. Um, we
have reserved an amount of money for
professional incentives. I want to call
attention to this in contrast to a
stipen uh because there will be goals
and metrics attached to these and the
[clears throat] additional monies would
be upon achieving those those set goals.
uh and additional money for supplemental
hours, family supports and resources,
and additional discretionary funds for
our restarts and redesigns.
Approximately about a million dollars uh
per campus and for our school
improvement uh in the ballpark of
$350,000
uh in those uh particular buckets.
Moving on to the actual timeline, um
this board meeting here is actually
bullet one in November. So, this is
where our board of trustees are going to
vote on the our taps. Um, tomorrow based
on the outcome of tonight, our our
staff, all staff on all campuses are set
to receive a preliminary preference
survey. So, regardless if they are uh a
TAP campus, TAP adjacent, or not
involved in a TAP whatsoever, uh all
staff members will get a preliminary
preference survey. Um, last year when we
were in a shortened runway to staff up
for some of our TAP campuses, we had
quite a few folks that said, "I
absolutely would love to go and do that,
but the timeline is short." And so, we
are going to capitalize on our timeline
uh now with this. Um,
thank you. Uh, in December, our
principles will be selected by our
superintendent to lead our TAP campuses.
And in January, we will enter into a
hiring freeze. uh that goes for central
office etc. There are plenty of
positions that uh our campusbased staff
um should have the avail the
availability to go into those positions
um and we will we will hold those uh
open until they are able to do so to
make sure that we are um helping every
single person that we can find a best
fit for next school year. Um we will
progress through the spring with uh
match fairs for those that uh would like
to meet some of our different principles
and and look at different campuses. Uh
we will have approximately three, but we
will not open up for external hiring
until April and that takes us through
the timeline of the spring.
This slide provides student achievement
targets calculated by our CDA
department. Um I just want to point out
that um the state accountability system
rates our campuses based on domain one
or two and three. Domain three is the
federal side of our account
accountability system for the turnaround
uh plans. We will focus on 2A and
growth. Um the district has set clear
academic goals to support improvement
and achieve a C rating which breaks
accountability. Uh we're focusing on
increasing student performance across
all grades and subjects. Emphasis will
be placed on student growth which I said
before particularly in domain 2 while
supporting emergent bilingual students
on tailpass and ensuring proficiency on
STAR assessments. These goals provide a
strategic path to improve student
outcomes and meet state accountability
standards. The turnaround plans are for
two years. So this would be our goal at
the end of two years. And we do have
provided for you the targets for
elementary and middle school. And with
that, I'm going to allow Miss Pace to
share.
>> Thank you. Yeah, as you can see, our
targets are clear and ambitious, and we
are aligning strategies to meet them. We
are prioritizing our emergent bilingual.
We are setting firm minimum
expectations, and MTSS fidelity is
non-negotiable. We are confident in
meeting these goals and we're not
starting from scratch. The core systems
needed to improve HQIM, curriculum based
assessments, PLC structures,
intervention systems are already in
place and being strengthened this year.
Our TAP monitoring and support systems
will accelerate the growth we are
already experiencing. Curriculum-based
assessments, weekly campus visits, and
frequent data reviews allow us to make
student and campus level adjustments
quickly and efficiently.
Increasing leadership capacity remains a
priority in our TAP campuses with
improved staffing timelines, dedicated
principal and principal supervisor
support, and targeted resources at our
highest needs campuses. With our aligned
systems focused support and consistent
monitoring, we're positioned to meet
these goals and exit turnaround status.
So, we do have one high school that's
currently uh developing a tap. Uh that's
East Side um Early College High School.
The campus is currently rated AD and it
has been identified based on the federal
le label of comprehensive support and
improvement. So performance goals for
the high school are aligned to achieving
an overall campus rating of a C um as
well just like elementary and middle
school. The goals focus on increasing
student achievement, strengthening
growth for all learners and improving
outcomes for student groups that drive
accountability. The targets are designed
to ensure measurable progress towards
state expectation and to position the
campus not just for improvement for the
moment but improvement beyond the CSI
exit. Um for the purpose of um
explaining CSI, it's when a school
performs in the the bottom 5% uh of the
state. So I just want to make sure that
I explain that.
>> I'll turn it back over to
>> Yeah. Thank you. Thank you, team. Uh, as
we wrap this up, I I want to be really
clear. Um, you know, there's there's
been a lot um that's gone into the
development of the turnaround plans. Uh,
and I also want to acknowledge that
there are um many things that have to be
considered and I thank you, Jennifer
Pays, for kind of identifying some of
those things. Uh one of the challenges
that we have as a school district is
that um we have many of them that we
have to work through uh and we have to
do them well uh implement well if we are
going to ensure that our students get
what they need to be successful uh and
also we appropriately can of manage the
state intervention risk. And so, uh,
there are a lot of, um, competing, uh,
elements and I'm certainly happy to
answer any questions, but I also want
our community to know that we are
building these taps upon work that has
been progressing for the last, um,
couple years uh, in a real meaningful
way. And so, there were a couple of
slides that I shared in the beginning
that showed the decline and the total
number of FC schools, the increase in
total number of A schools. Um and and
just I think it's important that we talk
about this because uh I I don't um want
our community to think that you know
this accumulation is somehow something
that we cannot um
go through and be successful at if we do
it together. Um I believe strongly that
we can. Uh and there's evidence that the
system is responding and some of those
uh are listed out here. Um, so with
that, uh, I want to hand it over to our
trustees and we're happy to answer any
questions that you may have.
>> Thank you all so much for the
presentation and the work and thank you,
Superintendent Sigura, trustees who has
questions.
>> Trusty Hunter, I was trying to let
somebody else go first, but I'm ready.
Um, on slide 11, can we put slide 11
back up?
>> [snorts]
>> Thank you. Um
I have a question about I want to make
sure we've we've had one grading period,
correct?
One nine weeks. Okay. And we've had a
boy, correct? Have we had an interim
star?
>> No interim star. Okay. Have we had any
um district um authored
benchmarks?
>> How many?
>> About three. My question is how many
parents
understand how well or how not well
their students are doing at this point?
>> Thank you for that question. So the
expectation is for campuses to provide
um reports to parents um from uh the map
data. They get their progress report
data and we had a day uh designated in
the fall for parent conferences. That is
something that we had not done uh
previously for secondary uh that we do
now. So, we did have a parent conference
day and we will have another one in the
spring and the campuses have been
charged with making certain uh that the
parents do understand where their
children are academically and how
they're progressing.
>> What is the percentage on attendance for
the parents conferences?
>> I do not have that data for you right
now, but I can get that for you
>> because that's how we got here. Sure.
Right. Um, and when we're talking with
parents, helping them understand, I, as
you know, am a teacher educator, and I
always tell my teachers, you need to
make sure parents understand that a 50%
does not mean their kid did 50% of the
work. It means that's what they got.
They could have done 80% of the work,
[snorts] but you're going to give them a
50 because it's hard to come back from
anything else. And I I still am not
comfortable that our parents,
we cannot hand them pieces, but they got
so much, right? I got a light bill. I
got a gas bill. What is this? Are you
doing okay in school? Good,
right? We have to we have to be able to
parents need to know he is really
struggling. She is not on grade level.
We have the tutoring. We noticed that
she hasn't been coming to tutoring.
That's family like engagement, right?
That's dual capacity. Hey, sixth grade
parents, ELA, every kid, we're going to
send you home with two books. Can you
check in on and if nothing else looking
out the kitchen is like get that book,
right? we have to help them.
>> Um, it's a partnership and we only have
them for so long and in these schools we
have them on Wednesday a little bit
longer, but it's still not enough. So,
I'm I really I need some data. I need
some numbers. I need to know that
parents understand what is going on.
>> Sure. I'll let you know or I'll explain
what our efforts uh will be to
strengthen this area because we do
realize there's opportunity there. Um
the campuses will be required to hold um
uh conferences whether it be virtual, in
person, teleconference because not all
families can come in person and we
realize that they need to offer multiple
ways for parents to engage. Number one,
we're going to have a tracker. We're
going to have the campuses document when
they contact parents, how they contacted
parents, and what was communicated.
Something that we did in the summer for
the restarts was train them over this
model with APT, which is academic parent
teacher teams. And that is um a model
where um it's beyond involvement because
they don't come in and just you know do
activities like a a literacy night or a
math night but they actually engage in
the teaching and the learning process.
So there is opportunity there. There has
been training on it but can we improve
in that area? Absolutely. Which is why
this is listed as one of our
opportunities. So the introduction has
been there. There is a process going
forward um to where we can uh monitor
more closely.
>> Okay. Thank you. Uh, I suffer some more
questions, but Mr. Superintendent, I I I
hear what we're saying and I keep
hearing the campus, the campus, they are
at capacity, man. They are doing it all
day, every day. And I don't know how we
can get support for that because you
work all day. And I understand like you
going to be making phone calls at night
on your way home and that um that's why
I have a Google number. Uh, but I'm just
Let's keep talking about that. Let's cuz
I mean it's November.
>> Um okay. Uh on page 16
I just really want to help uh that's the
I think that's Brandy slide chief.
What's that slide?
>> Yes ma'am.
>> Um
I know cuz when I first got this job I
was not even working right. Uh and
everything was a strain.
That wasn't me y'all. Um, everything was
a strain and I get it and I'm worried
about $300 and I'm over here talking
about $5 million.
>> I understand now that those numbers are
not even what we need.
>> A million dollars.
>> That's correct.
>> Right. That's like a $300 light bill and
you say, "Girl, I got 10."
>> That's what And I know we don't have
anymore, right? like it just it's but I
need our community to understand that
those numbers look big and I've been
talking to some um older residents and
they are very frustrated about those
numbers and I had to take time to really
talk about that that's nothing
it takes a lot it is a heavy lift and
we're not even compensating people for
what they're worth so um I really think
that that's something we need to be
transparent about like I would like to
see what it would really take and this
is what we got right I think that helps
people understand so that we don't wind
up in a situation people feel like we're
not being um
uh good stewards of the money that
they've entrusted us with to to teach
these children. Um the was the interim
star was page 11 page 16. Oh um no that
was it. I think that was just those two
pages. That was it. Thank you. [snorts]
Okay. Who else has questions? Justice
Sing.
>> Yeah, I really appreciate the work. Um,
and I'm glad to see that, you know, we
have a dollar amount for investments for
each of the schools. And um so one
question I had was
you know it's about the
the likely I mean so much of this is
about um
you know obviously the tabs are there to
so that we are sure we invest in the
schools that that are really needing
support. Uh I think one question I you
know but the other side of it it's not
really just up to us right tea approves
these plans. So I would love for the
superintendent to talk a little bit
about uh the tea success criteria
um particularly for the two campuses um
weedain and win. Um, I'm I'm really I
will say like I'm I'm good with with
everything, but I will I still have a
lot of hesitancy around these two. So, I
want you to reassure me um that TEA
will accept these because this is a
closure and reassign um for these two
campuses according to TEA's own success
criteria, not the law, but TEA what they
have the way that they have interpreted
and and created their written success
criteria, which I've asked Josh if he
could put them on board dogs. um it says
if you're going to do a closure and
reassign that it needs to be an A, B or
C school, but for when um that the kids
go to and that adopt that tap. Um
however, we are actually proposing two
campuses weed and and win to do closure
and reassign that are going to be going
to Dampuses. So please help me reconcile
this um which I think is a misalignment.
If you have talked to TEA and they have
given you reassurance, I want more
details on that. I think we really I
just if I'm voting on this, I have to
feel very very like 100% confident um
that we are we are giving TEA something
um that we that that they're going to
accept because this is displacing a lot
of people and I know that you care about
that. Uh I just want to I just need to
know a little more.
>> Yeah. So, I appreciate the question and
this is um something we've talked about
uh for for a little while now and and I
want to be really clear. I am not going
to bring anything to the board of
trustees that I do not think will be
accepted by the agency. I think to to be
clear like I would never bring something
that I didn't think would be accepted.
Um and as you mentioned uh the agency
does have different criteria success
criteria for this um specific response
um that does get amended um quite often.
In fact, it was amended not too long ago
because it used to be just A and B
schools. Um and so for our families and
for our trustees just about six or eight
weeks ago, it got amended and C's
campuses were added. So the agency um
does make changes. uh they are used as
um guidance as you said it's not the law
um we do engage with the agency I would
say on a weekly basis um it it is
something that was built up whenever we
enter into the TA greed order with
special education uh so we work with um
staff we work with um you know at times
deputy commissioners and we're asking
them all the time you know given the
comprehensiveness of the work that we're
taking on the number of schools that we
are um providing taps for. You don't
have the ability in every instance to to
be as responsive as as you'd like to be
regarding the criteria. Meaning, if it
was just A or B, then you might end up
having to move students across the
school district. Uh now that you've
added C, you have more flexibility, but
you still don't have the ability to meet
that everywhere. And so the guidance
from the agency has been if the school
district AISD is taking on a
comprehensive plan which we are with all
of these coupled with the programmatic
moves and ultimately the boundary
changes which boundary changes which are
coming uh these they look at the whole
and so uh what we've been really clear
about is if we're going to um move
students to a school that is um a D we
would look at the history in Rodriguez's
case last year they were a B um and and
they do not have a UA. They have they
have a D, not a UA count. They just have
a D. Um, and then we have to describe in
our turnaround plans the supports that
we're going to provide those school
those schools that are receiving
students that are currently a D. And
based on the stability that we've seen
at Rodriguez, because we're talking
about specifically with a um you know,
we have um extreme confidence that
they'll be able to meet the needs of
those students and ultimately um receive
uh a rating that'll break the
accountability chain. uh for when uh
Andrew is in Panon Springs. There are
two different uh elements here I think
that are worth talking about. The first
is the minority as far as student
population going to Pan Springs. Pan
Springs is also going through a a
restart itself. And so from the agency's
perspective, those students going to
that school like that will be addressed
and those students will receive what
they need and you're effectively kind of
um ensuring that that we are um meeting
the students needs by way of that
restart. So, um, that kind of helps
address that student population that
would be moving to to PCON springs. Uh,
for Andrews, um, given that it is a D as
well, um, it's it's very similar to what
we talked about with, um, within where
we need to ensure, okay, so what is the
history been at the school, what
resources are you going to deploy, what
other options are available to the
district, what A, B, or C schools were
considered, um, and why were they not
considered? And so, um, we go through
all of that. Um, we collaborate as a
team. We ask questions. We look at
different solutions. I will tell you
that we've made adjustments already. Um,
Woodane was a school that, you know,
what we heard from community and one of
the things I heard from trustees was the
split between Houston and Rodriguez was
one that introduced a risk of going to
an F school, right? And so we made that
change. Uh, but we don't have the
ability necessarily to move wholly into
another school that is is closer than
Rodriguez. So Palm ends up being you
know could you move them wholly into
Palm which is further away and so like
all of that kind of comes into it but I
would say that we have committed to
providing the resources wherever our
students go. Um they are uh guidelines
they are not um stated in law or
education code and um I feel confident
with the various conversations we've had
as a team with the agency that they will
be accepted. Um, as far as do we have
anything in written form, um, that is
not how the agency typically works. Uh,
they share with you their ideas. Um,
they will give you feedback. Um, but
they often don't put things in writing,
I think, just because that's just how
they work. Um, but we have had lots of
conversations and I'm happy to share
with you the dates and when those
occurred, the the timelines, I mean, all
those things. But I have a confidence
that it'll be accepted if that's um,
that's helpful. Okay. And then um
Okay. I appreciate that. I think it's
really important um for the
transparency. So I appreciate that a
lot. Um sorry, I really I So okay. So
that's let me let me let all that
marinate. Um I did want to go back to
something um that Dr. Maxwell talked a
little bit about was the correlation
between the the MOY um the middle of the
year maps and um the STAR test about 80
to 85%. Um, so
I so I even though we're not talking
about the three middle schools that
currently have taps today, um, I think
it is useful to think about bring them
into the conversation to get a sense of
how they've been doing um, to help us
understand or gain some reassurance,
confidence in
our work with all of these other tasks
going [clears throat] forward. So, um I
I raised this at the last board meeting
and have submitted a couple of trackers.
I did receive your email. Haven't had a
chance to read it, Dr. Maxwell. So, I
know that you um um but anyway,
can we hear a little bit about how we're
doing with um you know, Dobby and and
Lamar, Doby and Web and Bernett?
>> Um sure. I'll start and then hand it
over to Dr. Emerson and Dr. Maxwell. Um,
one of the things that I would say is we
were attempting to kind of bring in the
lessons learned based on what we
observed as we started up restarted
Dobby Bernon Web. And one of the things
that I think really impacted us was the
fact that that was approved on June 26,
>> right? So June 26 is when we approved
it. Uh, which meant that the hiring of
the principal, hiring of staff, all
occurred in a period when there are
very, very few staff available and
almost every educator has found a home
within central Texas. Um, and so I just
I just want to state that because I
don't I don't know if it's going to be
um easy to correlate, you know,
necessarily kind of how Bernet Web and
Doby have been going because we had to
catch up because of the compression from
23 24 25 accountability and when the
board approved that tap versus when we
started we literally had two and a half
months, two months runway to do it. In
this instance, we'll have you know
almost seven or eight. Uh so uh I'll
start there um and then I'll hand it
over to Dr. Emerson and Dr. Maxwell take
us maybe through more of the data
points. I do want to also tell our
trustees that based on that feedback I
do want to come back and do a deep dive
um either at the board information
session in December uh or the board
voting meeting to go through the three
schools in entirety in its entirety. Um,
and the reason for that being is that
there are some milestones that we're
going to receive over the next three
weeks, some data points that'll really
help us understand because right now
what you're going to hear is an
incomplete picture because the middle of
your like we haven't collected. There's
just things as trusty Hunter said that
you're still in the first you finished
the first reporting period and you're in
the middle going forward. So, I just
wanted to kind of caveat that because
>> there are some data points like right
around the corner that will really tell
you what you want
>> line. And so, given all that context, I
just really have been asking for a while
beginning of year this year was for
those three campuses versus last year.
Are they the same, better or worse?
>> Um, so the timing of that question makes
it it provides a little bit of
difficulty. The reason is that uh the
MAP assessment changed a little bit this
year. The assessment itself did. Um it
is still very very similar. It's an
adaptive assessment um that students
take and it you know kind of goes in and
out of different ranges to uh kind of
see what they know. They changed that a
little bit to be more the questions that
come up, the next adaptive questions
that come up are more focused on grade
level content. Yeah. um to make sure
that they are fully mastering that grade
level content before it moves them up.
And so the the test itself changed a
little bit and with the change of the
test they also um updated the national
norms. So the norms were from precoid
and so they updated the national norms
to how the nation is performing on this
test in the last several years versus
precoid. um overall performance in the
nation has declined and so they've
adjusted some of the norms of the
assessment. Uh what we tend to look at
are student achievement percentiles a
lot. We'll talk about this a little bit
more in our board report for literacy
and new mercy. Um but it's um that also
changes kind of the performance level of
these students on the assessment. So
math is one of the ones that has been
most affected by the changes in the
assessment and the norms as well. It's
not as much for language arts and um for
our restart campuses. Now, this year
we're actually doing it for science as
well. Um so, so with all that said,
comparisons from that we typically make
from which we've talked about a lot, we
should compare boy to boy and moy to
moy. Um it's a little more difficult to
do that right now because of the changes
in the assessment and the changes in the
norms of the test.
>> Well, I I'll mean I can wait till
December. It sounds like the answer is
probably no. like they're probably not
because I I imagine if they were better
you would have been like yes we're doing
>> well [laughter] we're actually talk we
had a couple of uh meetings this week
with NWA to further understand the
changes and the norms so that we can
adjust what we're looking at to make
sure that we're on target and we're
interpreting it correctly. So it's it's
a little harder to say yes or no
especially when it comes to math because
the performance is actually different
not just um from the new assessment but
in different grade levels. Um, so it's
it's kind of a complicated answer that
we're working on right now. Um, what we
do expect is the star projected
proficiency will still be very much on
target, especially that the test has
narrowed a little bit more to grade
level, not completely, but a little more
focused on grade level. Uh, it kind of
even tightens what they are tested on,
which should give us even a stronger
prediction for what that end of grade
end of year grade level assessment
should be.
>> I appreciate that explanation and
context. So, it sounds like we don't we
just don't have the right information
yet. it hasn't been interpreted all the
way through. So, I will be patient. Um,
but um, but I I'm really looking forward
to seeing that data and just really deep
diving into staffing and everything else
because I think that's going to be a
model. And the reason I raise it here in
this conversation is because I think our
community is going to expect that for
these 24 tabs as well,
>> for for the restarts. Um, perhaps the
the two UAS, right? Maybe not as much
for those, but but I mean honestly
that's probably something that we as a
board should talk about what what we
expect um as we track all this. And then
the other question is one um also that I
had brought up last time which was
around the um
the transfer arts. So, in our TAP plans
where students are going to be moved to
another campus, do we I would like to
know how many students are going to have
to have a transfer ar [snorts]
and do we have the capacity to do that?
Dr. Chirley is uh making her way up to
the
she's stuck.
Thank you. So, as far as requiring an
ARD, we are going to be requiring ARDS
for any student who is currently
receiving a centralized placement and
that placement would be changing.
Families are also welcome to request an
ARD and the campus will definitely um
hold that AR. So that will be um an
option and we're going to look at every
student as an individual student and
really look at their needs and the
determination of whether an AR will need
to be held. Keep in mind that ARS are h
annual ARS are happening all during the
year as well. So some families may want
to address or ask questions during ARS
that are being held in the spring as
well, but may not want to hold a
separate AR that may be, you know, uh
just extra stress on a family [snorts]
to have so many meetings scheduled in
such a short period of time. Yeah. And
trustee, I mean, sorry, Dr. Cherry Lee,
uh, I think it'd be helpful to maybe
describe how the platform and the and
the data system we have in place now
kind of helps us ensure that every
student is getting what they need in the
time that we have and that you have the
resources to ensure that if any new arts
that would not be otherwise completed
because of the change, um, we have the
staff to do it because
>> yeah, I mean, I think that's just need a
real concise. Yes, we we have the
resources.
>> Do we have a sense of how many are we
talking about? 100 kids or we talking
about a thousand kids?
>> So, we're looking at about Are you
talking about specifically turnaround?
Are you looking at consolidation
>> with with the turnaround plans?
>> It would have to be for a reassignment
or a or a closure because if it's
>> the student would have to be moving a
move.
>> Correct. So, we're looking at about 850
students right now, and that number may
fluctuate just depending on the number
of students receiving special education,
but we're looking at about 850 students
receiving special education that would
be reassigned.
>> Okay. And then out of those 850, how
many of them are required to have an an
AR before the transfer?
>> All of them or just
>> So, all students are required to have an
annual AR. And you so you're asking
which students would be a centralized
place are that
>> centralized placement
>> for those students that are receiving a
centralized placement that would I can
get that information to you. I don't
have that exact number on hand.
>> Okay.
>> Um but I can get that information to you
as well. And again families can request
an AR if they would like to to you know
further the discussion in AR. They could
also request just a meeting to discuss
what that you know if they had
additional concerns. Our team is going
to work very closely with staff and with
campuses to develop guidance for the
sending campus and also the receiving
campus again
>> so that we have a fluid transition plan
for students.
>> I appreciate that a lot. Absolutely.
Yeah. So, so the term is centralized
placement for the students that are
>> those those are the ones that would be
would would
>> would have to have one.
>> Correct.
>> Okay. And and we don't know about how
many those are out of the 850. Is it a
large? I mean, I guess you'll tell me.
>> It's a small number of students. It's
It's likely around 10% of those
students. It's It's not a large number,
>> but I can get the exact metrics to you
within um well, probably right after the
fall break.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> So, less than 100 or 100.
>> Okay. And you feel like confident that
we have the the capacity,
superintendent, to do those?
>> Oh, yes.
>> Absolutely. That's my main question.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. And we're planning for that. And
>> Oh, yeah. No, we're we are staffed up in
a way to to do this work that we've
never been. I mean, honestly, and with
this systems in place, we're better
positioned to support our students like
we never have before. And that's just
the honest truth.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Thank you, Trusty D. And then we'll come
to Trusty Kintana.
>> Yeah. I just want to ask a clarifying
question. For the other students that
are not centralized placement, how are
we modifying their paperwork to reflect
the new campus?
So within our system when students move
to a new campus that information will be
reflected in the digital management
system. So that that information is
documented through the system and it's
aligned through ERP. So ERP is where all
of our student information systems are
housed and that information
automatically will be updated when
students are enrolled at their receiving
campus.
>> Well, but my question is the student has
an IEP. It has the name of the campus on
it. How are you changing the name of the
campus without an IEP meeting?
>> How are we changing the name of the
campus?
>> Yeah, on the IEP it's going to say the
student is served at a specific campus.
If we close that P campus, the literal
IEP still has them assigned at the last
campus. So, how do you switch them to
the new campus? Don't you have to have
an AR to confirm the new placement?
Well, the the AR committee is going to
determine the services
um and the programming but not the
location of the services.
>> Right. My my concern is that any parent
go through initial placement when you
discuss the services they're going to
ask where are the services going to be
offered like the that that's how a
centralized placement would come up
right is that you would say there's an
option for service on another campus but
these parents aren't aren't going to
have that decision. It's just going to
say they've been reassigned to a new
campus.
>> So again, for those students that are
receiving a centralized placement, we
will be conducting an AR meeting and we
will be identifying that campus in the
spring. So the families will know where
their child will be placed if it's not
at the reassigned campus,
>> right? And so for the other students,
though, that's what I'm saying is like
they're not going to have had that
discussion. So I mean just in the
literal sense, if if we still had all
paper IEPs, I get that you have a
digital management system. The student
would have an IEP. It would say the name
of the school on it. And when they would
go to a new school, the new school would
have to change that IEP. They would have
to write an IEP with the name of the new
school on it. I get that we have a
digital document system, but the family
still has a procedural process to go and
change that. You don't you can't just
change the name on the IEP is my
understanding. You have to go through
the process to make any amendment to
that document. I mean, we'll we'll work
with our legal department on that as
well as it as far as the process of what
that could look like in our digital
management system. Um,
and we'll consider that. Um, I I I don't
believe that we would need to have an R
to change the reassignment of the school
within that our paperwork, but again,
we'll work with legal and with it to
review that.
Um, okay. I I mean I just have a concern
on procedurally how we were going to do
it.
>> Thank you for lifting that,
>> Jesse Kintana.
>> Yes. Hi. Thanks y'all. Um, I have just a
couple of uh clarifying questions in
general
um about restarts. Um it is my
understanding that um if a school I'm
sorry reassigned if a school is going to
um to be closed and reassigned to
another school that there were should be
no more than 20 students in each class
in that new reassigned school. Is that
true?
Are you talking about the staffing plan
associated with the um the the new
allocations based on what we're
investing and how we're investing?
>> I'm asking about the classroom size.
>> Yeah, it's it's not a requirement. In
our documents, one of the things that
we've committed to is um if it's a a
restart um or a 3UA, we are changing the
studenttoteer ratio, but it's not a
requirement. So then what will be this
the new student toteer ratio at
Rodriguez?
>> Can we please put the um uh slide number
nine back on? Thank you so much. Uh
thank you Trusty Canara. So this is a
proposal. So for our three UAS um you
can see by by level and right now with
what we're talking about we're strictly
addressing elementary and middle but
right now we staff at a 1 to24 uh K
through4 with a waiver. Uh we would have
a 1 to20 ratio. Um it would not be a
legal requirement of any sort but we
will try to keep those ratios much lower
than what we normally do for our 3UA
campuses. And then for our seat count
into our formula for middle school,
right now we staff at a 1 to 29 in a
large formula that has weights in it. Uh
we would drop that ratio that factor
down to 25.
>> Okay. I guess I'm just trying to do some
math here. Um so if Widen currently has
342 students and Rodriguez currently has
345, that equals 687.
Um, and if we were doing uh 20 students
max, like we're trying to do um with uh
27 classrooms available at Rodriguez,
that would be 540
students.
>> So, we're so we're not going to do
the 1:20 ratio.
>> We are going to try to keep it as low as
we possibly can with the space that is
available on that campus.
>> Right. But we have like numbers like
concrete numbers right now. So
>> of course for today's enrollment
absolutely.
>> Okay. So yeah I guess um are you saying
that we can't exactly say what the ratio
is because we don't know what the
enrollment will be in the fall.
>> So specific to to Rodri uh Wedane is
Wedane coming in as a 2UA or is it a
threeUA?
>> It's a three.
>> Okay. So so it's going to Rodriguez. uh
given that ratio we would have to first
of all we need to analyze the space in
there. I do believe that there are some
classrooms that are being not being used
as efficiently. I've spoken to Christine
Steamport about this. She's the expert
on actual space but um we would have to
keep you are correct if we are strictly
out of space and we have more students
than we than we have ratio or space for
for a 1 to 20 we will have to go to a 1
to 21. we would have to go to a one to a
22, but the the the effort would be to
keep it as low as we possibly could with
the space that we had.
>> Okay.
Um I also want to talk about um the
number of kids who are receiving special
ed uh special education in both schools.
Um they let's see
um
I have the numbers.
So, special education services for the
combined needs of 92 Rodriguez students
and 83. And so, when we're talking about
rooms and capacity,
um I'm worried that we're we're not
going to have the capacity to to give
our special education students the room
that they need. Um
when we combined
92 students with with 83 students,
Yeah. So, one of the things um Trusty
Katana is is that you know many of our
students um as a district about 74% uh
those students that receive special
education services are in the general
education classroom. Uh so the 1:10
ratio that that I think that would
trigger a modified
allocation by classroom would be like
life skills it would be a different
program. And so I would I I don't want
to speak to just merging the two and
assuming that that student population
would be a 1 to 10 ratio because that's
not how how that's kind of not not how
we operate and and kind of support
students who receive specialation
services. Um, and so I'd have to look at
the student populations to to be able to
tell you precisely how many of those
students would actually um contribute to
a 1 to10 allocation, 1 to 10 student
teacher ratio versus um the uh
recommended staffing ratio that was just
on the screen.
>> So that is that because the general most
of the students will be in general
education classrooms,
>> but I I'd have to break that down and
and look specifically at the students
services at those camp that campus. to
could I if I could jump in I mean that
does touch on to a question then is
without having looked at you know so
we're going to still have resource
scores SPS and life skills that all
potentially would need their own room
and so part of my concern is within
looking at all of those pieces um you
know those could resent result in
centralized placements that we're not
going to that we don't have any
prediction of yet and so you know as an
example you combine those two campuses
and you might say we actually need two
life skills and we can't fit two life
skills on the campus and so now you're
going to have to centrally place half of
those life skills kits somewhere else
and I haven't seen any data that's
showing how we can anticipate that. All
our staffing stuff has been saying that
we're going to look at that in the
spring but without having those numbers
you know there's the potential for a lot
of kids that are going to need to get
moved around.
So I think this is where the refinement
campus by campus I mean I when we
students come into school we different
student populations as they metriculate
through our our campuses um we make
adjustments all the time um you know
where it's we add prek maybe we make an
adjustment we we really try to to modify
our our st our space allocations based
on student need right and we've adjusted
the ratios um to ensure that every
school has an allocated number of
classrooms even though they may not have
need that number of classrooms. Right?
[clears throat] So that's why over all
utilization was actually dropped down
when we started this entire process
because we were kind of assuming whether
um it was the case or not that we were
going to protect these rooms for um
these types of services. So um I hear
you and and I think that's in the
details as far as you know how many
students may need to move or not move.
uh and you know we can you know provide
that data. I guess the question I I have
is um
you know when it comes to student
movement, you know, we're doing our best
with the number of facilities,
resources, funds like that we have and
everything is competing against each
other. Um and so I can provide a balance
of what that looks like, what it could
look like, but it really comes down to
getting the principles together, getting
all of our resources together, and then
planning student by student. And at this
point without a vote without, you know,
in the number of the scale that we're
talking about, I think the detail you
want, we're just not yet able to
provide. Um, but we know that total
student population, we're confident they
would fit at Rodriguez. Rodriguez not
too long ago was much much larger than
it is now. Um, and we do know that
certain schools don't use a space that
the way that maybe it could be used. Um,
and so, uh, what we can do is is provide
more detail around that. Um, I'm
confident that we have the overall
space, but space does move and get does
get used in different ways all the time.
Um, but we can provide that clarity
moving forward.
>> Yeah. I guess the the question that
leaves me with is given the the context
of the concerns and just physical space,
you know, if we get put in that
position, are we
it seems like we would have a choice
between moving sped students to a
different campus or putting more raising
the the cap on how many gened students
are in a in a room. You know, I'm just
thinking of my own experience when I was
teaching. I mean, you got to have a room
for for resources.
>> And that's why the ratio, I mean, we're
committing to to dropping down the ratio
um for general education classrooms to
the best of our ability. But but you're
exactly right. It's in there as
recommended, right? It's not. So, what's
fixed is the number of seats that we
have the building. We looked at
splitting up the student population to
address this concern. And what we heard
from community is don't split don't
split the school up. We heard that from
trustees, not don't go to enough school.
So, we even though it' be modernized
school at Houston. So we we had a
solution that addressed that space and
then we took it back and now we're going
to a school that wholly can fit
Rodriguez
um that's closest to Rodriguez. And so I
think this is just an example of how all
these things come to play together. Uh
and the real recognition that in the
area you have lots of surplus seats and
and so you know I would just say that's
that's kind of what we're going through
right now is what we've been going
through as we kind of arrive at this
final solution or recommendation I would
say.
Yeah, I think just the distinction is
that for some of the sped families, it's
not going to be necessarily about seats.
It's actually about the whole room
because just, you know, the grouping is
slightly different. And um I think it
would be helpful if you know we're
making some sort of guarantee that we're
not splitting up individual sped
populations from campuses because I
think that's part of the concern around
the centralized placement question
that's still open-ended is whether
programs are going to get moved around
because not every elementary is going to
have SPS or scores or
I would also offer back to the general
education question. and Trusty Canana
and Trusty Deos because of space issues
can also be creative with uh additional
pair professionals in the room uh to
help lower the ratio and and and if we
were in that situation um if we were not
able to expand by another teacher, we
can certainly put another adult in the
room, a TA uh that would help with um
assisting in that room. That there's
different ways to work through that.
Okay,
I think those are all of my questions
for now. Thank you,
>> Trusty Coffman.
>> Thank you. Um, I just want to understand
a little bit more about the space or the
projections in Southeast Austin. And so
I know that we have some communities
where our student population is growing
and others where it's shrinking. What
are the dem what are the um
demographers projections for that area
in terms of the capacity for the schools
in the next couple years?
>> Well, I I'd have to pull up the
>> I mean, has that been considered in
this?
>> Oh, yeah. I mean,
>> say that that the capacity is there
right now and it will be there in the
next few years as apartments build or as
>> there is a decline in enrollment in this
entire area. Um we had proposed until we
made the change in timeline even the
closure adjacent to this school which is
Palm you have a surplus of seats in this
area um a significant number of seats
and so um you know and as we talked
about the comprehensiveness of the work
that's one of the things we're trying to
balance out so yes there's there is a
surplus um I can uh trusty Kaufman if
you give me you know maybe 30 minutes 10
minutes I can pull up kind of the
general
>> the estimate for the area but we do have
a surplus you probably already looked to
this. I'm I'm I'm looking specifically
at the alternative plan presented by the
Woodane community where it mentions the
additional apartments being built in the
area that would be zoned to the school.
Um and it mentions the closing of a
charter school nearby that could
potentially reintroduce students to our
district that we could capture
>> um in a positive way, not if we were to
have spaces available. So, just wanted
to know if you've considered those
factors and what the response is.
>> Yeah. So the demographer um did meet
with um developments and developers that
um had been progress had progressed
their project far enough to have
certainty that the project would make
and so um I know consistently they did
that across the process. We actually
asked them to go back multiple occasions
whenever we heard from community that
there was something missing. Uh I think
sometimes um we think the student yield
is going to be bigger than what it is.
um you know and and we're talking about
you know over a thousand students that
are ava of empty seats in this area and
so with an apartment complex with a
closure of a school like we would still
have plenty of capacity um and so I
think it's just kind of order of scale
um now I can go back and and if you'd
like me to I can give you kind of the
details but we've been consistent about
um ensuring that our demographer went
back and asked the questions we've
identified in the report which
developments we are considering And if
we weren't the reason why, um I can't
speak to the adjacent development. Um
I'll have to look it up. Uh but in
either case, you're going to have plenty
of seats. Um that's just the reality of
of what we've seen in that part of
Austin.
And just in a in the big picture of
capacity of the district to manage these
plans and to support communities and to
um into making the improvements,
what would be the impact of
the board accepting
some of the
closure proposals and
rejecting one or two of the others in
terms of capacity.
Well, um I think about the whole um we
have, you know, over 20,000 empty seats.
We have a deficit budget that continues
to grow. Um we're trying to align feeder
patterns. We're trying to balance
enrollment. And so if any one of these
were converted from a reassignment to a
restart, then we would be then investing
the money into a restart. So the the
staff the everything would restart it
over and it would be one less closure,
right? So the the reduction in cost
offset would not exist, right? So
instead of closing 10 schools, you would
close nine. If you closed if there was
another one that didn't the board didn't
want to do, that would be eight. And so
the question comes back to the board.
You know, the expectation, I think, from
the board to the superintendent was to
do all of this and try to get to a
balanced school system. Um, and I would
just say that every time you add a
school back on, um, the question
becomes, are we going to take another
school off? Uh, is there another
resource that that we can identify that
would bridge that gap? Um because the
reality is that you still are going to
have seats even with these schools
coming offline. Um and so that would be
the impact. It would be us not being
able to get to a place where we do have
a stable school system. Um it would take
longer and I don't know what those
actions would be, but I think you'd
probably have to begin to reintroduce
things that have been previously taken
off the table at some point. Not
necessarily now, but you'd have to do
that. And what would you anticipate the
impact on that particular school? So
you've said that these decisions on
reassignment or restart were based on
specific factors infecting that school
on on a variety of things. It's not, you
know, those were independent decisions
based on the unique nature of each
school and their situation. So if you're
recommending reassignment for a
particular school and the board were to
say we will not vote in favor of
reassignment but we would vote in favor
of of a restart. What would you
anticipate the impact on that school and
community and the students to be in
terms of our capacity to support that
school individually? Not the big
picture, not the boundaries, not the but
for that school. If we're thinking about
each of these turnaround plans as an
individual Yeah. component that a school
needs to be successful in the state
accountability system.
>> Um,
we're talking about a district manager
restart because we've lost opportunity
to do a charter restart, just to be
clear. Um, that would be the thing that
would reduce the risk the most given the
two-year pause. Um, but I have heard
from our trustees consistently and from
our community that's not something that
we we want to do or should be doing if
there are other options. And I heard
that from this community as well when
I've been there and I've also heard it
since then with other community members
um in the area. Uh so a restart, you
know, it would turn over the staff. We'd
have to meet the expectations in the and
from the agency
um you know and and start that work. So
is it possible? I mean I I of course I
mean we can we can we can do those
things. I would have to very quickly
within hours you know try to do almost
the impossible and change the documents
to upload
um you know and and I think we
you know you ultimately get to a place
where
we're not removing risk necessarily
across the system. you know, from a
budget risk perspective, from
implementation risk, that's one more
restart that we have to work through and
and that's we will do it, but I just
want to be honest like, you know, these
are hard. These are very hard to do and
we're doing lots of them already and
doing one more. We hadn't planned on
doing one. Again, it's the board's will.
Um but it would uh I don't want the
board to think that it'll necessarily
um ensure that
the system as a whole uh will be um they
will meet our overall goals and and I I
understand you know I understand the how
would a in the community the position
the adjacency to um to everything and
and and I think that's why my focus has
really been about you know menda
and trying to figure out how to
[clears throat] kind of take Mendes back
and position a strong school at Menddees
uh in the future. And I know these are
very connected. Um and so I just want
you to trustes to know like that that's
how we're thinking about it. It is hyper
specific to the school. It is regional
with all the other schools. Um what I
wouldn't want to have happen is this
instance where Mendes and Woodane are
both not there, right? That's something
I don't think our board would want. I
certainly don't want that. Um but the
reality is we do have um lots of empty
seats and the school has accumulated the
unacessable accountability ratings that
require an action by the by us or the
agency will do it for us.
>> And and just to be clear, I'm not asking
about that one particular campus. I'm
really asking generally about the
decision- making. I really want, you
know, I understand that we have to make
decisions
for the the whole district and that
every decision has impact and a ripple
effect, but at the same time, I also
understand that every one of these
campuses has an individualized plan
that's meant to be community developed
and in partnership with the community
and specific to the actual needs of that
campus. And so I just want to ensure
that we're going into this looking at
each campus individually and not, you
know, at the same time as recognizing we
have constraints around that. Yeah.
>> But that it's that, you know, we're
looking at this campus individually,
that this campus plan has been
identified as the one that's most likely
to lead to long-term success for the
community and for the students that it
serves, etc. And that's just what I
really want to probe on is just ensuring
that these that when we vote for these
that we're voting in good conscience
that this is what's going to be that
we're not sacrificing a community for
the greater good. that we're finding
solutions that will benefit every
community while sustaining the district
for the good.
[applause]
And and to be clear, I'm not saying that
that I I'm saying that's the commitment
we
saying that's the that's the
communication that we need and that's
the commitment and promise we have to
make to the district and we have to say
that that is genuinely what is
happening.
>> Yeah. or we need to change the plan. One
or the other, right?
>> Yeah. And and I think um
I think our board has seen I I think our
I hope our community has seen like when
we can adjust we do. I mean we made
adjustments on many of these turnaround
plans already. Um our community has
shared with us things that will work,
things that won't work, but there are
also constraints that we're operating
in. And if if the objective of the board
is to not make those requirement of the
superintendent, then then that won't be
the case. But I have to get to a
balanced budget. I have to address the
accountability risk. I have to do the
address the TA agreed order. I have to
do all of these things at a point when
we have limited resources. And there are
certain things that I can adjust and and
modify and improve on. And I think we've
done that well where we can. And there
are some that um as much as I want to do
it, I know that it it'll be difficult
for us to implement or um it ultimately
isn't going to move us toll towards that
collective goal. Um even as much as I
want to do it and there are lots of
schools and lots of changes in these
plans that that I'm I'm really sorry
about. I mean, I feel devastated that we
have to do this, but I just we just
don't have options. I mean we we are
very limited in what we can do. Um the
question I would have is you know if if
the number of seats and the number of
turnaround plans and the number of
accountability risks that we're managing
are not as of the same concern as before
then I would need to know that. Um I I
would need to be to be clear as far as
my direction goes because I've been
trying to manage all of these
collectively on behalf of AISD and um
and there are just some where I can make
adjustments and I I've I heard from the
community that a split wasn't going to
be work. I heard that don't send
students to an F-rated campus even
though it would be modernized. We made
that adjustment. We we wanted the school
to be together. We we made it work at
Rodriguez based on the feedback we've
had for the agency. It works. Um
you know and so that that still is is
responsive but not necessarily back to a
completely different change in the plan.
Um and so so I just want to kind of note
that because we are really trying to be
responsive. It's just there are some
things that we can't do without changing
our overall objectives as a system for
like the years. Um that's just
>> thank you. And I just repeat, I'm not
asking just about Wedane, you know, I'm
also asking about Bington and Betachic
and Wyn and
>> Dawson and Martin. Like I just want to
ensure that we're communicating honestly
and clearly to the communities that we
are doing the very best we can to
provide the plan that will be help their
community to be successful. So thank
you.
I have a clarifying question or from our
experience. Um when we were here last
year or doing the same thing um the call
was save our school and the community
wanted that and we said yes community
does not understand what that meant. The
thing that they loved about their
school, their principal, their teachers,
that's the thing that has to turn over.
Um you think, well this teacher is a
really great teacher, so she's going to
stay. But that's not the measurement at
which teachers are looked at. And I
really, it is still breaking my heart.
Um that when I, you know, talk to people
at Doby and they're like, "Well, you
know, Miss and not here anymore, and oh,
she's over at a whole another school,
but she's still doing something over
here after school."
I there's no good choice. All right.
Literally, that's a Sophie's choice. You
restart the school. The thing that you
love about the school, you don't have
anymore.
I I don't I don't like I don't have an
answer for that, but I really think it's
important that the community understand
that because my community did not,
right? They did not know the teachers,
the ones that were working the hardest
didn't meet this description that we
get, right? And then the principal has
to be a special kind of principal. Um, I
don't know if that's an um, if it's like
different because this is a tap and I
mean this was like more UAS, but I just
want people to really understand like
what that means.
>> Yeah, I think um, Trusty Hunter, thank
you for that. Um, and and when I talked
about the strategies, the fact that
Woodane and I think we're still talking
about Woodane is a 3UA. Um, the district
manage restart would include precisely
what you said. um we'd have to ensure
that 60% of the educators in the core
instructional areas um met the
definition of highly effective. Again,
not Matias's definition, not the state,
not these people's definition, it's the
state of Texas definition. Um so there
are a number of years of experience, uh
TIA designation, um nally board
certified. There are things that that we
have to um ensure uh our educators have
in those classroom spaces. And then uh
we have to ensure that the principal has
demonstrated the ability to turn around
a campus. And that is a very clear
definition going from an F to a C right
that is and that is not something that
many principles have. Right? It's just
not um and the state also kind of looks
at the administration that's there. Um
who was there when when the the school
accumulated the unacceptable
accountability counts. Uh and so all of
that requires effectively a pretty
significant turnover. Now, we work
really hard to make sure we have
familiar faces. We look at classified
staff that can stay. We look at
essential areas like all the other staff
that we can stay. We want to keep them.
But it is a different school uh when
when this uh gets done. It just is.
>> I just I just want people to understand
like if that's what you want, understand
that's what you're getting, right? I
just I just really want that out. Thank
you.
>> Thank you, Trusty Kintana. Well, while
we're speaking about staff, I guess I
would just like to ask and clarify these
numbers that I have in front of me that
at Widane there are five teachers with
TIA
uh designations. Uh 10 teachers who are
highly effective or distinguished
um and that about 91% of the staff is
certified. um 96% is teaching within a
certified field and um around 88 have
three or more years of teaching.
>> I don't have those specific metrics in
front of me, but I can confirm your
first measure about the TIA designations
because as a part of our um uh list of
of how many teachers across the district
were qualifying and I have that by
campus. Um but to be clear, there's TIA
designation and then there's TAP
eligibility which is a slight expansion
of that. Um uh for Wedane specifically
and I know this because I was speaking
uh to the principal yesterday there are
uh I believe eight teachers that meet
that expanded uh within that expanded
eligibility uh eight core and then there
are an additional eight non-core being
essential areas prek
uh etc as defined by tap standards
>> that meet
>> that meet TAP eligibility. Okay. So
that's 16,
>> correct?
>> Um, and then they have 12 classified
staff and TAs. So that would they have
to meet any sort of requirement?
>> They do not have to meet any sort of
requirement. We want uh we want a blend.
We want familiar faces for our kiddos in
all spaces.
>> Okay. So that's so that's good. So
that's like 28. And then they have two
people in the front office,
five people in the cafeteria, [snorts]
three people on the custodial stop. So,
as as far as the turnover and and
familiar faces, I mean, um it's a
concern. It's heartbreaking to have to
let our teachers and principles go, but
I just want to clarify that this
wouldn't be an entire sweep
>> correct
>> of the school.
>> Yeah. So, I would say trustee Canthana,
yes, that's that's exactly right. Um
which is why I was referring to the 60%
as the minimum uh criteria. The one
thing I want to say is um we are going
to hire a principal for this school if
it was to be a restart. Um and one of
the things we need is for that principal
to be able to identify his or her like
leadership team. It's really important.
You know, if you just bring a leader in
without the ability to hire anybody that
is going to support them, it's a
challenge. Um, so I you're right, it's
not a complete sweep, but I also don't
want the presumption after this meeting
concludes that every single person you
just listed would would perhaps remain
because there would be some space there
for that principal to make his or her
own decision regarding like, you know,
administrative staff that are closest to
them. I mean, one of the things we've
observed, right, wrong or indifferent,
is that if that leader isn't able to
hire the people that they're going to
rely on to move the school, um that it
doesn't always work out. And we have
lots of examples of that in Austin ISD.
So, I just wanted to you're right, but I
just wanted to kind of put that little
note [clears throat] just because that's
how it might work out. But, yeah, it's
not a clean sweep. It never is. We don't
want it to be, honestly. We want
familiar faces. We want our staff to
feel welcome. We want students to see
faces that they they know and love.
>> I appreciate that and I appreciate that
um clarification because that's the
first time I think that I've heard that
little nuanced point. Um but you know I
think they have a lot of great teachers
to choose from. Whoever the principal
is. I know that um was it in 2019
Whitane was a B-rated school. Um I'd be
curious to know how many of the teachers
that um were teaching at that uh time
are still there. Um because um you know
I think that our
accountability system has changed a lot.
Um how we test our students has changed.
But um I would be surprised if the
quality of our teachers have changed um
if they were a B-rated school
six years ago. we can provide that data
to you.
>> So just the number of teachers who were
there then that that were are there now
in the areas that were grade level like
third grade and above who contributed to
the rating. Okay.
[snorts]
>> Thank you. Anything else?
>> Trusty Singh.
>> Sorry. Um okay. So I just have to just
pause for a moment and just appreciate
that weedane went up from 49 to 57 last
year this year
and I know that other schools I know
went [applause] do you happen to know
does you probably have this memorized
but I just feel like we have to
recognize that many of these schools are
actually on an upward trajectory. So
trust um trusty C I'm glad you brought
that up because I gave a presentation
that I shared with the entire community
that like kind of listed out the
progression of each school.
>> It t I mean and I you're right. I mean
these schools have gone from you know
40s to low 50s to high 50s. It's very
frustrating because we have I think near
a dozen or between a do about a dozen
that are between 59 and 58. They have a
59 or a 58 and they're right there. And
I what I also tell communities and this
is what is very frustrating also is that
the agency sees an F and it's an F. Um
but you're you're exactly right and this
is why in the video that I sent I was
very clear and I even talked about like
the progression and the move and how the
many of these schools were B's in 23 in
22 and then were an F in 23 and then 23
24 25 they've been climbing out. Um and
and they are so very close. Uh so you're
exactly right. It's heartbreaking. It's
so infuriating. I mean, so when went
from a 45 to a 57, I mean, it's just
>> I I should stop talking, but I'm really
sorry that this is a situation, y'all.
Like, this is really terrible. And from
what I'm hearing, you know, um, if we
were to convert Wedane and and went back
to a restart instead of a closure and
reassign, we'd have to replace
some of the most important people
on those campuses. Correct. To do a to
do a restart and meet the TAP
requirements set by TEA.
>> There there would definitely be a
movement of staff, but as to trustee
Canana said, not all staff.
>> Not all staff, but
>> and it depends on the school. I mean,
honestly, some schools don't have the
same numbers.
>> Um, I can't I don't want to speak to
specifically how many
>> WIN does versus Wedain, but every school
has a very different number. Um, so some
could be much less than, you know, the
seven plus the the remainder could be
two or three. Some could have a much
higher percentage. Just depends.
>> Okay. Um, and the other quick point I
wanted to just bring up is I do want to
thank thank you and the staff for um for
[snorts] the adjustments you made to um
Sanchez and and Pickle and was there
another one?
>> Yeah, there's Yes. Um there are several.
Yeah. So Pickle, Wooten, Sanchez um you
know kind of win Monastery working
through that. Um and but that's maybe
part of the conversation but yeah,
>> but I did I feel like I'm I'm throwing
you under the bus. So, I want to make
sure like you really I do appreciate um
and recognize all all the good work
here. Um and I just wanted to also add
when we're looking at the restart at the
I'm sorry at the TAP plans and [snorts]
I I very much appreciate um the response
to the questions I had around the
baselines versus the targets. Um so in
the tap plans there's a a target metric
you know for each thing that you know
the star you know we expect x percentage
of kids to get meets on the algebra star
or you know whatever and um we don't
have the baseline in there I but my
understanding is you you created those
targets based on what would it would
take to get that campus up to a C. Is
that correct
>> to break the accountability chain?
Correct. Yes. C or better.
>> That's a C. Okay.
>> C or better. Sorry.
>> Okay. That's fine. And then um and then
did you I believe you did create a
spreadsheet that actually has the
baseline for each of the campuses. Was
that
>> um
>> is that available if we wanted to know
just so we get a sense of like so for
East Side for example we're it says in
their tap that this year like the year
we're in right now 22% of the students
will get a meets or above on the algebra
one star. Okay. Last year they were at
11%. I'm sorry, no, 25% for this year.
Last year they they were at 11%. And so
we're more than doubling, you know, the
percentage [snorts] of kids who are
going to pass the start in algebra this
year. So I just, you know, but I had to
kind of look up their taper from last
year to get that. So I think it would
just be very helpful for us in our moni
like the next phase when we're actually
monitoring all this to have a clear
understanding of the baselines just like
we do with our scorecard you know real
clear understanding of the baselines and
um and and the targets and really
understanding like okay do we even know
how close we are to getting to 25% of
east side for example and like what
markers are we using to help determine
that.
Yeah. Uh that's ex that's ex exactly how
uh we are going to we are doing it. Um
the one thing I would also offer is that
um percentages can be deceiving
sometimes because uh student populations
are vary from campus to campus. Um and
this is I think one of the challenges we
have with really small schools. Um,
we've talked about this a lot with our
schools that have about 150 to 180
students where one student movement,
well, a a family moving out, right,
could change a school from a C to an F.
It it happens. It It happened this year
in 2025 multiple times.
>> And so, at a high school like East Side,
you think about, well, the student
population is less than 700, the number
of students that are taking the class
versus, you know, it it you you realize
that it actually is very attainable. Um,
you know, we can make we can move. Um so
the percentage increase and I chu text
like I would expect them to increase by
that amount because the starting point
is so low they need to double.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. Um so I just I think when we show
that work we can maybe be very trans
very clear about where we are how the n
or the number of students multiply by
the percentage uh or actually tied to
after the multiplication occurs uh is is
being supported so that we're very clear
as to how we believe we'll meet that
target. Um okay. So because it can seem
as though it's a huge jump, but really,
you know, given what we're tracking,
it's very we can do it, you know. So I
think that's what's lacking and what we
need to produce and how we'll track it
on our end.
>> All right. Thanks so much.
>> All right. I have a few questions. Um
first, can you explain the difference u
between the schools that have to put
this into action immediately next year
and and kind of whether you get a C or
not, how it impacts different the taps,
the tips, the different plans. Some are
taps that go into effect and some are
taps that may go into effect.
>> Yeah. So, um what you're referring to,
President Boswell, and in our community,
um for awareness, it's really a
difference between three UA and two UA
campuses that are being um developed
right now. So, the compression of the
release of accountability ratings,
right? So, we had 2023 released in the
spring of 2025 and then we had 24 and 25
accountability released August 15th,
16th, something like that. Um, and so
what happened is you had schools that
got their second and third UA like at
the exact same time from a release a
requirement date. And so the agency um
gave guidance to all school districts
and again there are hundreds of school
districts and hundreds of schools that
are doing this right now. uh they said
if you have a 2UA develop your plan it
must get approved and then you'll
implement at the start of 2627
uh for three UAS you develop the plan
and you begin to implement as soon as
the start they get approved effectively
so spring um 2026 right um and so for us
because some of these are um restarts
some of them are reassignments you know
the way that we've structured it is the
reassignment action will occur next year
but the work leading up to in the the
things that we're doing now as part of
that plan are occurring in the spring
semester. Um an example of that will be
hiring, right? So, we're going to hire
principles for these schools in um in
December and and then they're going to
start kind of building out their team in
the spring. That would be an action
that's in alignment with the TAP that'll
be implemented already being implemented
but fully actionable in 2627.
Um if it's a 2UA, you know, obviously
two UAs are mostly school improvement.
We're not going through that process
because that'll be the following year.
Is that helpful?
>> That is helpful. Thank you. Um
and uh on slide five, I know we have the
1882 contingency and it's written
specifically into the summit of the
plans. It's available. I know. Um, can
you help me understand if
um closing a school is an option in the
same way in 1882 is if we have a school
that we've put together and we feel like
it's not going to be successful.
>> Yeah. So, um, when this occurs, it's
when a school um,
uh, is in the year where they're taking
the summit of assessment or taking STAR
in the spring semester that would
contribute to its fifth UA, right? Um
and so the the way that it would work,
and this is really um for those schools
that are are further along in the
accountability process,
um you cannot if you were to choose a
school closure versus a um a 1982
turnaround plan, the students would
still take the summit of assessment or
the STAR um before the closing actually
occurred. And so it doesn't um protect
you from having um the intervention of a
school closure or installation of a
board of managers. Um which is and so
the the the flexibility in 1882 is that
it gives you the it consumes that first
pause year in that fifth year. Um, and
that allows us to to restart again if we
need to uh allows us to restart, monitor
growth because as Trusty Singh said,
many of these schools are right there. I
mean, they're they're right there. And
so a D is a pause. Um, you know, we
fully expect I fully expect to have to
have way fewer F schools um because of
the great work that's been going on and
just the period. Um, so they're not they
can't be used interchangeably. Was that
helpful?
>> That is helpful. Thank you. Um and I do
want to pause and really share what our
caller shared, what so many of my
colleagues have shared, what you've
shared. Um is just thank you to everyone
who has been doing so much good work. Um
to our educators, our principles, our
classroom, teachers in the classroom,
all the staff on campuses that support
our students have obviously been working
really hard. Um our families have been
working hard to support our students. Uh
and it is to interrupt that rapid
progress is painful. um and scary I will
I will say because we know this is
working in a lot of places and we're in
a really hard place where this is the
solution.
um we have a short menu to pick from and
and I just want to really um echo what
I've heard is that we know people have
been doing such good work because we see
it paying off and we also see the
passion that people have for our schools
that families are so excited to choose
these schools and and I think it's on us
to even as we're having to do these
painful things to do everything we can
to offer those supports to keep that
momentum and to keep families feeling
like they have a place and to make sure
our students feel like they have a
place. So, I just want to pause for a
minute and and share that appreciation
and that recognition. Um, I have a
question on slide 12,
the continuous of continuous evaluation
of work.
Um I think to Trusty Singh's point kind
of how do we track this and and I will
say knowing what's what with um the
three schools right now with Doby Webb
and Vern it's a little scary not to know
whether we're making progress halfway
through the year that's really
frightening and a quarter of the way
through the time that we have. Um and so
I really we adopted a constraint on our
scorecard. We changed our scorecard to
make room for this very specifically.
And um to the superintendent, I would
really love understanding how all of
this is going to be evaluated if you can
bring a calendar to us, a recommendation
to us about how we're going to track
this. I see you looking at Dr. Maxwell
in a way that suggests you may already
be talking about this. Yeah. [laughter]
>> So, I I really um after we're past this
moment, if you could bring that to us, I
think that would be really valuable so
we can know as a board and so our
community can know how we'll know if
we're doing what needs to be done. So,
thank you for that.
>> I I think um December information
session or December board meeting would
I mean we we want to share that. So, um
yeah, we we can definitely do that.
>> Yeah. And I think just a calendar for
sharing sharing it about all of the
schools um with our community I think
would be really valuable. I don't know
if that looks like a dashboard board
meetings um progress monitoring but this
is a big deal and it's really
existential
um for our district remaining hours um
you know with our community voice and
really want to be sure we're being
thoughtful about that. Um I have a
question on slide 16.
um if we believe that these um
strategies are valuable, the
supplemental hours, the family supports,
um some discretionary funds on that
campus because I you know I think we've
been talking about campuses know
themselves best, right? Um why is that
not part of the school improvement work?
um if we think that's important because
we are trying so hard to keep those
schools from falling into that um spot
and if there are valuable strategies,
what can we do to help make sure that's
funded?
>> Yeah. So, I would say um
every
it adds up quickly. Um, you know, I was
obviously pushing the team to to really
be thoughtful about the allocation of
resources for um, our three UAS as well
as two UAS. And as you can see, it adds
up quickly. You know, when you sum these
two together, it's, you know, 18.25
million. Um, and I also want to be uh,
clear with our trustees and with our
community, like we're actively pursuing
like grants, like anything that can help
offset this cost so it doesn't all hit
general operating budget. Um there are
there are certainly things that we can
pursue and partnerships we can explore.
Um you know we kind of backed into and
used staffing as the primary driver. Uh,
but I also want to be really clear that
there's flexibility within these line
items, which is why I didn't put
allocated amounts and use kind of
estimated number because what happens is
as you get into each school, um, there
are, you know, one school may need 7%
versus, you know, and fewer dollars for
discretionary funds or they have another
resource they can rely upon. Um, so I
guess we we could add that um to those
schools if we needed to. um regarding I
mean given the number and if it was the
same allocation maybe something slightly
less just to kind of start um I can
certainly talk to Katrina um and see you
know if it was like 30,000 or 25,000 um
coupled with the money that they have
already does that help us kind of move
along because I'm going to have to
multiply that by the number of of of two
UAS and you know it'll add up but I I am
certainly happy to look at it we can
explore it and I don't know team if
that's something the board wants I mean
and again it doesn't have to be codified
in this document What I can say is we're
going to explore it and then bring it
back as part of the budget because this
is for the next fiscal year. Right.
>> Right. But I can certainly do that. Do
you want to say
>> I was only going to add sir that it also
uh Trusty Boswell uh with the staffing
allocation it actually will free up
quite a quite a few dollars that they
have that they are spending right now on
staff and title money that they can also
reallocate in those ways. And so this or
that it can we would much rather you
know be able to take the load of of
trying to keep a staff member and take
that load off and let them use those
dollars in a disc um which would do the
same thing.
>> Thank you. I appreciate that. And I
think you know I think our community has
shown a real willingness to um a crisis
is an opportunity for people to see
needs and to see you know what not
everyone has to pay attention to all the
time. the lack of funding, you know, the
shortage of funding, the high stakes
accountability, what's at stake if we
don't help our students in the way that
we need to help them, that we very much
want to help them, that we are helping
them, just not at the speed, you know,
we have to accelerate that. And and I do
think um there's a moment to really lean
into our community, these are our
community schools, and lean in and say,
can you help us? You know, we don't have
these things here. We would like to have
these things here. So lean on us as well
for to be your allies in that because we
aren't the people doing it in the
classroom. We're not the people working
directly with our teachers, but we are
out in the community and can be supports
to that if you feel like that has value.
So thank you for that. Um my next
question is um what kind of analysis was
done? Um I'd just like to understand are
we looking at individual students going
to these campuses based on the
populations now? Are we looking at
comparable student populations in other
districts? Like how do we have a sense
that schools with these percentages of
emergent bilingual students, these
percentages of students with economic
disadvantages, uh these percentages of
students who are scoring at certain
things on the star? How do we have faith
and confidence kind of what work have
you done to understand the populations
you're putting together and why we
believe this will be successful at each
of these campuses?
>> Yeah. So I'll start off and you know I'm
certainly happy to to add um kind of all
these reports here that we've been kind
of accumulating and building over a
period of time. And what we did was um
we we um used estimates based on um
projected reside as well as um kind of a
an assumption regarding distribution of
students at any split campus. An example
of that would be if a school has, you
know, 60% emergent bilingual student
population and that school is splitting,
then we would, you know, kind of take a
weighted average and apply that to the
receiving school. And then we would kind
of use a calculation to just rebaseline
and figure out, okay, what is the new
expected um emerging bilingual student
population or the new uh student
population that identifies the climate
disadvantage? all of the groups. And
then we took that and we compared it to
other schools in Austin ISD as well as
other school district other schools in
the state of Texas uh to see a um could
schools with similar demographics be
successful and the answer is yes, very
much so yes. Um how much of a change did
we see um in in each of those
distributions? And and what I'll say
it's it's it's quite small. um you know,
you might see a school go from like 38
and a half percent a merger bilingual to
39 and a half percent or or 40%. They're
all really quite small. And I think a
lot of that has to do with the fact that
in many cases they're similar student
populations and you're adding to the
numerator and the denominator at the
same time. Uh and these are all
relatively close to each other, right?
So when you think about the city of
Austin, you know, just kind of
geographically, you don't see huge
swings when there are two schools that
are near each other. And that's what we
have in most cases. Um and so that was a
could the student population of the
profile be successful? Yes. The second
question is based on historical um kind
of uh summit of assessments for each
student. This is kind of projection
based. You know what do we think the
projection will be of the combined
school. Uh we ran those numbers. We have
those numbers. We know um kind of where
we end up and it I think in many cases
in almost all cases it it puts us in a
position to be successful. I don't want
to I also want to be really honest. You
know, students when they come into a new
school community, it it could feel a
certain way. You know, we have to make
sure we have the supports or it may not
work that way. But we've done the
analysis um and we feel that the
movement within the student populations
doesn't move us too far up or down the
spectrum that makes it to where we won't
be successful. There's evidence in the
state of Texas and there's evidence in
our school system. Uh, and I'm happy to
maybe even post these um, you know, but
but we did do the work.
>> Thank you. I think our community, some
people are curious. I I think it would
be fantastic to post it. I think
especially because you are doing the
work. Please, uh, I think that would be
really valuable to people. Thank you for
that and thank you for the explanation
of how you got there because I, you
know, there obviously is a deep amount
of work in this. It's, I think it's
helpful for people to hear. Um, so I
went and pulled the data from the 2025
STAR campus level data at the state and
I pulled out I I have special concern
about middle school. Um, I think for
good reason and you know historically
that's been a challenge for us. I think
we're seeing it with Doby Webb and
Bernardet that that we're there for a
reason and I know good middle school
work has been done. But um I pulled all
the six through eight middle schools
that are not charters in the state and
three of the the 15 middle schools with
the highest concentration of emergent
bilingual students are in Austin ISD and
all three are campuses with Fs. And I
really want to understand at campuses
when we're putting together, you know,
we are a geographically segregated city.
We are a linguistics linguistically
segregated city. We are an economically
segregated city. We're a racially
segregated city. And when we are putting
campuses together that happen to be
nearby,
um we are matching need with need often.
And I really want to understand um with
language especially you see a higher
correlation
um with lower campus ratings with
language than you do with economic
disadvantage um which are two of the
categories that that are on those
spreadsheets. And I really want to
understand how we are going to make sure
if you learn language. Um so much of
your language learning happens like
this, not in a classroom. Your hours in
the classroom are limited. Um and the
language you're speaking on the bus, on
the playground, at lunch, at home, um
often, you know, outweighs if you're
speaking a language that's easy or
comfortable that you're not learning,
outweighs what you're doing in the
classroom. What is our plan to make sure
that our speakers of Spanish and other
language really get um that exposure to
English that they need to be really
successful by the time they're in middle
school testing in English um you know
that we want to help our students retain
their language, but we also want to be
sure that they are successful
um in our system under the
accountability system we have and in the
world when they graduate by being truly
bilingual. What are what is how do these
plans include that?
>> Yeah, thank you um President Boswell.
So, I'll have Dr. Maxwell maybe just
kind of touch on it and then hand it
over to you. Um Kas or if you want to
kick it off either way.
>> Yeah. Oh, sorry about that. Um so I the
plans really address this I think in a
lot of the work that we've been doing
this this last year and that we've um
increased this year um and have really
started concentrating really doing some
some concentrated things in middle
school uh as well have to do around
language development. Um, yes. Uh, one
of the things that we know would benefit
are, you know, exposure to English when
they're in the in the, you know, in the
the playground in all the spaces in a
campus. Um, there are different levels
of vocabulary that are spoken in those
in those spaces. So, those that's very
common vocabulary. Um, and it's not
necessarily academic vocabulary or the
kind of vocabulary that English language
learners need on a regular basis to
truly access learning. um and really
change the uh student outcome
trajectory. So, one of the really things
that uh the really important things that
we continue to focus on is whether
you're in a one-way or you're in a
two-way uh dual language program, you
are focused on language of instruction.
Again, we keep talking about that it's
such a simp it seems like such a simple
thing, but that provides significant
access in the academic uh classroom in
academic structure that changes the kind
of uh language that students are
actually acquiring.
um the added benefit of additional uh
English speakers, English native
speakers in that classroom in a two-way
or in a one-way because we have both of
those situations just the ratio is
different in the classroom. Um is that
you do have uh I called it language
brokering I think a couple of uh
meetings ago. It's that's the back and
forth with the two languages. So you get
more exposure to the language that you
are not native to um just by way of of
uh being around each other. But really
that improves significantly when it's
focused on academic learning. Whether
it's talking about math, whether you're
you're in your language arts portion of
the day. One of the things that we've
started uh training our staff on and
then have rolled out multiple trainings
this year um with instructional leaders
and with teachers is uh CBLI,
contentbased language instruction, so
that you're marrying content and really
strong language uh uh strategies when
you're delivering that content. And that
again that is across all content areas.
Um so that is something and at the
middle schools um we've added a few
additional tools that um campuses are
using to uh monitor where they are in
their language acquisition and then they
actually have some instructional pieces
in those tools that help teachers
respond to where students are in English
language acquisition and then have uh
things in the classroom that they can do
that that respond to that. um that is
all all part of our our strategy for
emergent bilingual. There's a very
specific section in these plans that
speaks specifically to emergent
bilingual. Um but those those are really
the highest yield strategies um that
that exist that we've already started
implementing. But yeah, they're they're
definitely a specific part of this plan.
And um Miss Godenus, I don't know if you
wanted to add anything to that.
>> Well, Dr. Maxwell, very well said.
[laughter]
I just want to go ahead and reiterate
the importance of language of
instruction. Um again just repeating Dr.
Maxwell said but we are also investing a
lot of professional learning and
supporting of teachers to maintain that
language which is um we have the
language allocation plan for dual
language programs and it's really
looking at content and language together
in the development of both. So it's
academic language as well.
>> Thank you. I appreciate that and I
appreciate the academic language. I can
talk to someone a bus on a bus and I
can't talk about math. So yeah, I
totally get in Spanish. I totally get
that that there are a lot of gaps
because I didn't get that academic
foundation. So thank you for that in the
same way. Um so my last questions are
really about the the choice of DTOF
campuses. Um, I've shared my concern
about that, you know, with with
turnaround plans and our choice to do
things that are not um,
NEA success guide recommended. And and
we know that initially it was um, F
campuses that were reassigned were
intended to go to A or B campuses. Um,
with this cycle, they changed it to A,
B, or C, but the documents nowhere say
D. and and we you know I I I trust that
you've had all those conversations and
that tea the people you're talking with
are telling you it will be okay and I am
really struggling um partly because
that's a big lift for a campus that's
struggling to not be a D and needs to be
successful and partly because the whole
point is um we need our kids to be in
environments where things are working
and we don't want to further stress
schools that are making that progress um
that needs to be sustained and we need
plans that are going to work. Um, and we
need plans that DEA is going to be okay
with. Um, and you know, telling you in a
meeting is not the same as having them
approved. And, and I would just love to
hear from our council, our board counsel
um, and our general counsel about um,
where the rules live, kind of the
difference between a law and a rule and,
um, kind of what risk we have, and then
what happens if our plans are not
approved.
Uh thank you President Boswell board of
trustees. Um so I think what you have
referred to I know is in the success
criteria. Um and I understand the
superintendent and the team have you
know worked with the uh work with tea
and the understanding is that we are
producing plans that we believe will be
approved. So I'll just first kind of
comment on the process. I think you
understand that we have to submit once
you know if this board approves those
plans then we'll submit it to TEA for
approval. Uh but if there are things
that need to be adjusted or if they
don't believe that the plans as
presented um meet their criteria or are
sufficient then they will respond back
uh to the district and give us an
opportunity to make any adjustments. And
they're also within that process
required to be specific as to what they
believe needs to change. And after that
occurs, then we'll have an opportunity
to resubmit. Um, and so I guess I'm
highlighting here that there's more than
just one opportunity to ensure that
these plans are successful. Although I
know we've worked on the front end, as
the superintendent indicated, to ensure
that we're going to be presenting plans
that will be approved. Um, that criteria
that you're referencing, you're right,
and I know it's been said before, it is
not law. It is a success criteria, which
has changed from my understanding. There
are many different iterations, but it is
one of five criteria. And there's a list
of other criterium that has to be
indicated that I understand the team has
worked through to ensure that the plans
meet. Um, and so I know, you know, with
with what we've worked through, I think
we've tried the best our c we can and
with the team to make sure that these
students end up in in campuses in which
they're aligned for success. Um, but I
know that there there are some instances
in which students are not going to A, B,
or C campuses. But I believe there's
other plans again in place to ensure
that those students are successful and
we'll throughout the process I think
there'll be an opportunity if there
needs to be changes uh for those changes
to occur.
>> Thank you. I appreciate that. And yeah,
Miss Bio, I'd just love to know kind of
your thoughts on it and and as a trustee
being asked to vote for things that um
don't align with what TEA has published
that feels uncomfortable.
>> Yeah, understandably so. I would say in
terms of difference between law and a
regulation, the law is the law. It's
passed by the legislature, but as uh I
know you're very familiar with uh
chapter 39 and 39A. Um they leave a lot
of room for interpretation and that's
the function of the regulations. So the
regulations and plug in the gaps.
Outside of that, TEA has uh regulatory
guidance that they issue that is doesn't
carry the weight necessarily of law or
regulation, but it it's what they use.
it's how they interpret those things.
So, from the standpoint of feeling like
you're being asked to um approve
something that is not necessarily
consistent with what that regulatory
guidance might suggest is optimal or
what they're looking for. Um yeah, I I
get the the cognitive cognitive
dissonance that exists there. Um, but I
do uh and I know you all know that your
administration has worked exhaustively
with the agency to try to make sure that
um that you're you've got plans uh that
that you're considering right now that
they will approve. Um so
as far as the inherent risk in that I
think it is risk that you've been living
in and it's risk that you're going to
continue to be in it. I I don't think
there is a path forward that is that
frees you from that. You are going to be
living in this space tonight, tomorrow
night, and probably for the next several
years. And there's no way to really make
that any easier. There just isn't.
>> Thank you. I appreciate that. Um, and
I'll just say the campuses I'm the the
plans I'm most concerned about um are
win with uh Andrews which has a D
carrying the tap and some students going
to Pan Springs which is a multi- um UA
campus. Um so the stress of that on Pan
Springs and um just that that divergence
um from best guidance um concerned about
the Wuen going to Rodriguez with a D.
That concerns me. Um glad the community
is staying together under this plan
which I think is better than it was but
that does concern me. Um
especially with Palm there and I know
Palm was listed to close but Palm was
right there and isn't a D. Um and then
the Waldridge restart sending um a
significant number of students to
Bington.
Um I mean Bington to um Waldridge. Yes.
Concerns me with Waldridge having the
need for a restart and absorbing more
students from Bington. Um that is a
concern to me of adding again extra
stress to a system that is already under
stress. Um and then uh Betachch and
Pettis that concerns me. Um and and
Martin Marshall which has been um
working very hard that has a D and has
been working very hard to pull out of
that and again adding u more stress to
that system. So, so those um those all
concern me um not just from a it doesn't
work on paper, you know, from what TEA
has said, but just
are there enough resources to help
manage that stress, especially because
we know students are bringing um
mobility during the year. They're
bringing hunger. They're bringing a lack
of health insurance. They're bringing a
lot of other things in that stresses our
systems. And I have real concerns and
and I appreciate the video. I think that
was helpful. Um, but I still just really
want to voice those concerns.
>> Um, yeah, President Boswell, I
appreciate that and those are our
concerns as well. Um, I think if we had
options um better options uh that still
allowed us to progress as a system
forward, we we would have that's what
you would see um in your documents. I
think when we started this process, one
of the things we heard from trustees
loud and clear was not to um perhaps
overload a school and and that's why we
created splits, you know, and I would
argue that Woodane splitting to
Rodriguez in Houston was in a response
to what we heard initially in this
process of not having a school that
needs that type of support wholly going
into one school. And after we went
through the process, we heard from
community that they wanted to stay
together. So, we made adjustments in our
plan to to be able to take that on um
and do it well. And so, uh and then we
talk a lot about the fact that these
are, you know, these are ratings and and
our students are more than a score and
our schools are more than a score. And
so, like Rodriguez being a a D now being
a B last year,
>> you know, I like you know, these schools
are doing incredible things. They they
are. And
>> I think you have to look at all of it,
not distill it down to a single letter
grade. Um, and I think that when we look
at the the work that's occurring all of
our campuses, um, these are the options
that we've arrived at given all the
constraints that we're managing and they
don't fit in a clean box. Um, the TEA
box, you know, uh, they never it was
never going to because the system is so
complex. Um, but we have a path that I
think um, moves us forward. um you know
and and we'll hear what they say and
we're happy to make adjustments um if
they're not accepted and we'll be
responsive as we always have been.
>> Yeah, thank you for that. And I I will
tell you I'm one of the first people to
say that the scores measure one thing.
They don't measure everything. Um and
they don't measure who our kids are or
the work that's happening on campuses um
or how much our kids are learning and
growing and figuring things out. and
it's the measure we have to live by. Um
that is the measure we have to meet um
while we are doing all the other good
things for our kids. Um these measures
matter and and I do have I just um I
know I voiced it before and um I just
want to continue to voice it because I
do have real concerns. Thank you. Uh any
additional questions? Trusty Hunter.
>> I'm going to a little bit point of
clarification what the superintendent is
just saying just so the community can
understand. Um the plans are due for
everybody the whole state tomorrow.
That's correct. That's part one.
>> Tomorrow close of business.
>> Yeah. That's hundreds of them, right?
>> Yes.
>> By March, I think is the 17th. What is
it?
>> Uh well, so there the before they have
to give a response. Yes.
>> It's 60 days.
>> 60 days. So then they will say you're
good, move forward. Or they'll say no,
you're lost or no, there's a cure
period.
>> Uh yeah. So what they'll do is um and
it'll be before I expect because we've
been able to engage with the agency this
entire time that it won't take 60 days.
If you recall when we had the taps
approved for Burnet Web and Doby it was
within a couple weeks even though they
had allocated you know 60 days. So I
would expect that I would push for that
um to occur. So I don't expect us to
wait 60 days before we get a response
from the agency. uh if as trust as
Kenneth Walker mentioned our general
counsel um we would expect to get
specific comments that are actionable
meaning that if there is a a tap that
doesn't meet their expectations for
whatever reason um comments regarding in
red lines specifically as to why it
doesn't work uh and then we would be
responsive to it. We would then have the
ability to submit an updated plan and at
that point there would be review period
and then acceptance. Uh and again at
that point we would effectively we' we
have we'd have to have a really good
reason not to be responsive to those
comments right like like we would ensure
um 100% acceptance at that point
>> and then the final so we we send it they
look at it they review it if there's
issues it comes back to us and then by
what date are they're like okay go to it
[snorts]
>> is it 15 days after the second
>> I think isn't it April
>> April 8th it's by date now
back up. I just want everybody to be on
the same page. Yeah. Information.
[snorts]
>> Thank you. Any additional? Yes.
>> So, one quick clarification is in filing
these at that point, it doesn't matter
what the school gets this year,
>> we have to implement no matter what.
>> So, it depends if it's a 2 UA or 3UA.
>> Three UAS.
>> Yeah. So, the two UAS are drafting right
now. Um, and we're submitting. Um, those
are all the school improvement um
schools and they were listed there. Uh
but 3UA um they have to implement.
>> So even if they got an A this year we
still have to implement.
>> Correct.
>> I'm so sorry.
>> Point of more clarification for our
community.
>> So there are taps that are written to be
like you on the list. There are taps
that are implemented saying you must do
these things. Right. How are they
differentiated when we say 2 UA 3 UA?
[snorts]
>> Yeah. So um so two UA predominantly um
>> which means unacceptable
>> two unacceptable unacceptable
accounts and again it doesn't
necessarily mean two Fs it could be
three Ds and an F. It could be four Ds.
There are lots of ways that you can you
can get there and again these go back to
2018 2019 school year. So here you go.
Thank you. Um the two UAS uh are um in
almost in every every case um a school
improvement uh uh strategy unless
they're receiving from another school
and then that strategy is modified. Um
and so you can see here there are 12
schools. They're all listed there uh
that are identified as school
improvement. And so when we submit to
the agency tomorrow or sorry yeah
tomorrow it'll all be there. uh and then
we would um kind of implement fully in
2627 we would plan but we would really
implementing that school year for three
UAS we're getting started now
effectively [snorts]
um you know we have to assume and and
I'm going to assume that by and large
these will be largely accepted I do not
expect a significant change maybe some
refinement in an area or two and the
reason being is that we have to hire
principles we we have to start the
process because we do not want to miss
the opportunity in the spring semester
to um to ensure that these schools are
fully staffed. And so we are going to
proceed and again I'm going to push the
agency to give us um clarity sooner than
later. Uh but that's how we're going to
differentiate between um 2 UA and 3UA.
So closure and reassigns and restarts
are 3UA and then school improvement is
all 2 UA.
>> Okay. And all the schools that have to
implement I mean in the state of Texas
are all going to need turnaround
principles.
>> Correct. So Austin at 11 or is it 12?
>> Uh so
[snorts] so the the restarts are it's a
combination because one of the things
that I want to be really clear is if a
school is going to a high performing
school right in this case like I'm going
to use Bington as a good example. The m
>> to yeah Bington is going the majority of
the students are going to grow Thompson
and so therefore Bington's turnaround
plan is going to be assigned to Gro
Thompson. um from the agency's
perspective because um GT has been
historically high performing they would
expect that school to have very little
disruption and continue to hyper to
perform right because they've they've
set up systems they've implemented well
um so you're not expecting a disruption
in that case meaning that there's not
going to be a turnaround plan that has
us suggesting in any way that the
principle at GT is going to turn over so
I want to be really clear even though it
is a a tap 3UA it doesn't necessarily
mean that we have to find a turnaround
princip Excellent.
>> Which is why the team and I have gone
through and built strategies for each of
these and depending on the vote tonight,
we'll kind of begin to take that
forward, but it's not always one for
one. There's going to be some some of
that shifting.
>> And then you may see that there's a
school that has a TAP plan, but is also
closing
>> tap plan, but al so um so by way of a a
reassignment. So what I think you're
referring to is a school like Betachch.
Is that is that correct? when
>> when uh that's exactly right. So um when
when monastery um has three UAS uh
they've been progressing as trusty singa
to a 59 um and I suspect they're going
to get to a DA or not better this year
for sure. Um the way that it works is uh
the majority of students that are being
reassigned in this case to Andrews
Andrews will receive the turnaround plan
that went historically that had
accumulated because that's it's based on
where the assigned students are in the
attendance boundary. That's how it
works. Um, in our conversation we're
about to have regarding all the other
movement in the system, you know, you'll
see the monatory program get relocated,
but those are two separate actions. One
is owned by the administration and by
the board and the others kind of in
response to turnaround plans. That is
also going to be true for um, uh, uh,
Martin, Dawson, Betach, um, Bington as
you just mentioned, which is a closure,
right? Uh, and then Whitame. Okay,
>> I'm getting into the weeds of that so
that people can understand what is
happening because if you think it's one
thing and you're like you don't have to
do that. It's not necessary to do that
and you can feel that but there's I
don't want there to well yeah as much as
there can be I don't want there to be
asymmetry uh of of information right you
know what I know so you understand why
I'm doing what I'm doing
>> thank you
>> thank you any additional questions
all right um thank you all so much for
the work the conversation the
information and thank you superintendent
Sigura and thank you to everyone who's
come um for the other part of our
meeting as well for waiting while we had
a a really thorough thoughtful
discussion about this as well. Um so at
this time we will adjourn our public
hearing, take a short break and then
return to open the regular voting
meeting. Um Vice President Willie Chu I
have a motion to adjourn the meeting.
>> I move to adjourn the meeting. Uh the
meeting is adjourned at 7:32 p.m. and we
will back be back in just a very few
minutes.